Hey everybody, we are going to be covering something really, really important, which is ML engineering. Some folks might have never heard that term before, but ML and AI is becoming extremely important. I saw some stat the other day. Basically, almost all the Fortune 500 companies have whole teams dedicated to AI and ML. It's kind of accelerating so many different areas. And so a machine learning engineer is going to become a bigger and bigger field as we kind of move forward. And so super excited that we have Liran Hassan here to talk to us about ML engineering, what it's all about, how you can get skills in that area, and what those folks do all day.
大家好，我们今天要讨论一个非常非常重要的主题，那就是机器学习工程。有些人可能以前从没听过这个词，但机器学习和人工智能正变得极其重要。我前几天看到一个统计数据。基本上，几乎所有的财富500强公司都有专门的团队来负责人工智能和机器学习。它正在加速推动许多不同的领域。因此，随着我们不断向前发展，机器学习工程师将成为一个越来越广阔的领域。因此，我们非常高兴 Liran Hassan 来到这里，和我们聊聊什么是机器学习工程、它的全部内容是什么、你如何在该领域获得技能，以及这些人在整天都在做些什么。
So thanks so much, Liran, for coming on the show. Thank you. Thank you for inviting me. Cool. So let's talk a little bit about kind of your background. So what has been kind of your experience with ML engineering? How did you, you know, kind of get into that? And how did you kind of move on to where now you're kind of building tools to serve that community? How did that journey go for you?
非常感谢 Liran 来到我们的节目。谢谢。谢谢你的邀请。好的。那我们来聊聊你的背景吧。你在机器学习工程方面有哪些经验？你当初是怎么进入这个领域的？又是如何一步步走到今天，开始构建工具来服务这个社区的？你的这段经历是怎样的？
Sure. So, well, my journey started way, way back when I was 10 years old, just being super curious about building websites. It started with that. Wait, really building websites it started with that wait really building websites at 10 that's amazing yeah well just a friend of mine just called me and kind of told me he built a website and i was like what does that mean right and he just read kind of 200 long characters of a website address. I was typing it one by one. And suddenly I saw his name on my screen and my mind just blown. Like it was like, whoa, that's crazy. Yeah, so that got me curious.
当然。嗯，我的旅程要追溯到很久很久以前，我10岁的时候，当时我对制作网站充满了好奇。一切就是从那开始的。等等，真的吗？从10岁做网站开始的？太神奇了。是的，其实只是我的一个朋友打电话给我，跟我说他建了一个网站，我就问：“那是什么意思啊？”然后他就念了一长串大概有200个字符的网址。我一个字一个字地把它敲进去。突然，我看到他的屏幕上出现了他的名字，我的脑子直接炸裂了。就像是，哇，太疯狂了。是的，这让我产生了好奇。
And I was like, how did you do that? I have to learn that. So yeah, I learned and then I saw an advanced capability called html so i asked my mother to buy me a book about html i started learning continued to asp free and php and all this is history like these languages almost non-existent today then kind of moved into more software engineering so for example i saw a lot of people, kids at my age, who were trying to learn software engineering, but were struggling with the language barrier of having to know English.
我就想：“你是怎么做到的？我必须学会这个。”所以，是的，我开始学习，然后我发现了一种叫做 HTML 的高级功能，于是我让妈妈给我买了一本关于 HTML 的书，我开始学习，接着又接触了 ASP.NET 和 PHP，所有这些都已经是历史了——这些语言在今天几乎已经不存在了。然后我转向了更多的软件工程领域。例如，我发现很多和我同龄的孩子都在尝试学习软件工程，但他们都在语言障（需要懂英语）碍前举步维艰。
So I wrote kind of a programming language in Hebrew. It was called Blue-White Programming. All my friends actually laughed at me about doing that in my summertime. So, hang on, we got to back up a little bit here so so at 10 you're already really adept at using a computer right so so you must have gotten a computer at maybe seven or eight or something or yeah something like that um that is wild and so was that uh like uh so you got a home pc around seven or eight and then um did you have in uh grade school you know typing classes and all of that or was this all done at home no it was all done at home wow amazing okay so so then you you got into uh you know the web programming
所以我用希伯来语写了一种编程语言。它叫做“蓝白编程”。我所有的朋友其实都嘲笑我在夏天做这种事。等等，我们得倒回一点。所以你在10岁的时候就已经非常擅长使用电脑了，对吧？所以你大概在七八岁的时候就拥有了一台电脑，或者类似的东西？是的，差不多是那样。那太疯狂了。所以你在七八岁左右就有了家里的个人电脑，然后你在小学里上过打字课之类的吗？还是说这些都是在家完成的？不，全都是在家完成的。哇，太惊人了。好吧，所以你后来接触了网络编程
stuff and then you got into kind of compilers and writing your own languages and that was maybe later or was that also at 10 no no obviously that was later i'm talking about 15 16 something like that um i learned c c plus plus um i was like really interested in understanding how everything works uh down to learning the assembly x86 and stuff like that. Wow, amazing. Okay, so yeah, tell us about that. I mean, how did you evangelize that? And was it the kind of thing where just folks locally knew about it?
之类的内容，然后又开始接触编译器和编写自己的语言，那可能是后来的事？还是说这也是在10岁的时候？不，不，那显然是后来的事。我说的是15、6岁左右。我学习了 C、C++。我真的非常有兴趣了解一切是如何运作的，甚至深入到了学习汇编 x86 之类的东西。哇，太神奇了。好的，跟我们聊聊这个吧。我是说，你是怎么推广它的？这只是当地人知道的那种事情吗？
Or were you able to kind of get the word out? And how did that look like? No, so it was mainly online for the days of ICQ and then Messenger, and some online forums. There was no Facebook back at the day. I know it might sound weird for some people. There was no TikTok. Yeah. So, yeah, it was very, very different.
还是说你能够把消息传播出去？那是个什么样的情况？不，这主要是在线进行的，在 ICQ 和 Messenger 的时代，还有一些在线论坛。那时候还没有 Facebook。我知道这对某些人来说可能听起来很奇怪。也没有 TikTok。所以，是的，那是完全完全不同的。
So I was sharing it with the world online on a couple of forums. One of my projects got published on a newspaper, which was super exciting for me. And then I got my first job at the age of 17 years old as a software engineer. So that's kind of how I got into software engineering in general. With machine learning specifically, my first experience was about when I was 18 i built i built a software to do biometric identification by taking pictures of the iris and this was built in matlab again another thing that i guess that today outside of the academy you won't see a lot of people using yeah isn't that wild how matlab has uh i think there's still know, there's probably some tranches that they have, but outside of there, MATLAB has kind of totally fallen out of favor. It's pretty wild. I remember using Octave back in the day at university, which is for folks who don't know, Octave is an open source fork or not fork implementation, I guess, of MATLAB. But yeah, I really doubt universities teach MATLAB now.
所以我通过网络在几个论坛上与全世界分享它。我的一个项目还被登在了一份报纸上，这让我超级兴奋。然后我在17岁时得到了第一份工作，担任软件 engineer。这就是我如何普遍进入软件工程领域的。具体到机器学习，我的第一次经历大约是在我18岁的时候。我构建了一个软件，通过拍摄虹膜的照片来进行生物特征识别。这是用 MATLAB 构建的。又是一个我想今天在学术界之外，你不会看到很多人在使用的东西。是的，MATLAB 不是很疯狂吗？我想它现在可能还有一些特定的应用领域，但在那之外，MATLAB 已经完全失宠了。这挺疯狂的。我记得上大学时用过 Octave，对于那些不知道的人来说，Octave 是 MATLAB 的一个开源分支（或者说实现）。但是，是的，我真的很怀疑现在的大学是否还在教 MATLAB。
Yeah, no, and their neural net library is, I don't think they've got updated since like many, many years ago. But today everyone is using either Python or R, so there are better languages to use. Anyway, kind of skip away. So I spent five years in technological unit in the israeli army um graduated as captain i won't get into the details of what i did there but it wasn't related to software so wait so at 17 you had a software engineering job right and was that the
是的，而且它们的神经网络库，我觉得好像已经有很多很多年没有更新过了。但现在每个人都在使用 Python 或 R，所以有更好的语言可以使用。不管怎样，我们跳过这部分。我在以色列军队的技术部队呆了五年，以少校军衔退伍。我不会深入探讨我在那里做什么的细节，但它与软件无关。等等，所以你17岁就有一份软件工程的工作，对吧？那是军队的工作还是军队之前的工作？不，那是入伍前的工作。哦，我明白了，我明白了。我懂了。然后我想军队是18岁左右吧，对吧？好的，明白了。所以你有点像……你提前高中毕业，或者说17岁在以色列是个正常的年龄。然后你有一年的时间可以获得一些行业经验。接着你有一些军队经验。那你实际上在某个时候去上大学了吗？还是说你直接从高中进入了行业？这是一个很好的问题。是的，我确实在某个时间点上过大学，但那是我全职工作的同时进行的。
army job or that was pre-army no that was pre-army oh i see I see. I see. And then I think army is like 18 or something, right? Okay, got it. So you had kind of like a, like you finished high school early, or maybe 17 is a normal age in Israel. And then you had a year where you were able to do some industry experience. And then you had some army experience. And so you actually, did you go to college at some point? Or did you go straight from high school into industry? Well, it's a great question. Yeah, I did go to university at some point in time, but that was in parallel to me working full time.
那时我已经在一家初创公司担任工程师了。那么你对这件事有什么看法？我是说，那些正准备高中毕业、可能不知道自己在大学里想学什么、并且觉得他们想直接去找工作的人，你会给他们什么建议？你会推荐全职工作、兼职还是全职上学？或者如果你今天要给出建议，你会对他们说些什么？我认为这非常非常因人而异。有些人需要有课程、家庭作业、项目以及指导这样的框架，那是他们学习新东西的最好方式。如果你是那种人，
And that was when I was already working for a startup company as an engineer. And so what is your feeling about that? I mean, folks who are, you know, let's say graduating high school now, and maybe they don't know what they want to do in college and they're feeling that they want to go and get a job. What sort of advice would you give them? Would you recommend the full-time work, part-time or full-time school thing? Or what would you tell them if you were to give advice today? So I think it's very, very much individual. There are some people who need to have the frame of courses with homework, with projects, the guidance, and that's their best way to learn new stuff. And if you're that kind of person,
那么是的，显然去上大学或学院。另一些人则更适合自己学习。如果你是那种人，我绝对会建议你利用空闲时间去做一些项目。如果你能在大公司里找到一份真正的工作，哪怕这意味着从初级职位做起。归根结底，没有什么能比得上动手实践。老实说，作为一个既有大学经验又有在初创公司工作经验的人，我认为每一段经历都为我提供了不同的方面和视角，至少当我在处理机器学习项目时是这样的。
then yes, obviously go to university or college. Other people are better just learning on their own. If you're that kind of guy, I definitely leverage that for using your free time to work on some projects. And if you can land some real work in some company, even if that means starting at the junior level, by the end of the day, there's nothing similar to hands-on work. And to be honest, as someone who has both experience from university as well as from working for a startup company, I think each one of them provides me with different aspects and different perspectives to, at least when I'm coming to machine learning projects.
它不仅帮助我获得了动手实践的经验，还让我对幕后发生的事情有了更深入的了解。没错。比如数学是如何运作的。所以如果你真的想做好你正在做的事情，我认为这也是很重要的。是的，这说得通。所以，好吧。你在 MATLAB 中构建的东西——我也在 MATLAB 中构建过一堆几乎无法投入生产的东西，你知道，比如它们经常崩溃，或者真的非常慢。所以这就引出了一个问题：你如何运行这个多节点系统？所以，在某个时候，你撞上了机器学习工程的南墙，也就是真正让它创造价值。那段经历是怎样的？
It helped me to not only have the hands on practice, but also to have deep understanding of what's going on behind the scenes. Right. Like how the math works. So I think this is also important if you really want to be good at what you're doing. Yeah, that makes sense. So, OK, So the thing that you built in MATLAB, and I also built a bunch of things in MATLAB that are almost impossible to put into production, you know, like, like they fail constantly or they're just really slow. And so it's like, how do you run this multi-node? And so at some point you kind of ran into the brick wall of ML engineering, you know, actually making this create value. And so what was that like?
你是怎么处理这个问题的？是的，就在退伍后，我加入了一家名为 Adalone 的云安全领域的初创公司。我是核心创始团队成员之一，我们真的是从头开始构建一个产品。我们有数据科学团队，他们在构建一些机器学习模型，而在某个时间点，我被安插到了
How did you kind of deal with that? Yeah, so just after the Army, I joined a startup company in the cloud security space that was called Adalone. So I was one of the core initial team, and we built a product really from scratch. And we had our data science team and they were building you know some machine learning models and at one point of time i was placed inside of
那个团队中，目的是为了建立合适的底层基础设施以便投入生产。正如你所提到的，我真的很高兴你提到了这一点。迈向生产环境并不是一件理所当然的事。进行研究、在 MATLAB、Python 或 R 中构建东西，与将这个产物转化为生产环境中一个正常运行的服务，完全是两码事。是的，那么那家初创公司，里面有很多机器学习吗？
that team in order to kind of create the proper infrastructure for reaching production because as you mentioned and i really i'm really happy that you mentioned it. It's not trivial to get to production. There's one thing of conducting your research, building something in MATLAB or Python or R versus taking this artifact and making a proper running service in production. Yeah, and so that startup, was there a lot of ML?
那是那家初创公司业务的核心吗？所以他们才需要那种基础设施？机器学习绝对是我们的主要业务方向之一。所以我们本质上在做的是监控企业正在使用的云服务。因此，当时很多公司开始过渡到云端，无论是 G Suite、Dropbox 还是 Salesforce 以及所有这些解决方案。所以我们一直在帮助他们真正了解他们在这些服务中有什么活动，并识别恶意的攻击者行为。现在，为了做到这一点，这就是我们利用机器学习的地方。
Was that core to that startup's business? And so that's where they needed that infrastructure. ML was definitely one of our main lines. So what we were doing essentially is monitoring cloud services that enterprises were using. So a lot of companies started to use back in the day, you know, transition to the cloud, whether it's G Suite or Dropbox or Salesforce and all of these solutions. So we were helping them really get visibility to what activity they have in these services and identify malicious attacker behaviors. Now, in order to do that, that's where we utilize machine learning, right?
比如我们为每一个用户以及不同的设备建立了行为基线，并且我们利用机器学习来识别这些用户行为模式中的异常，然后说：“哦，等一下，这看起来不像该用户的传统行为，这可能是一次攻击。”所以这就是我们使用机器学习的地方。酷。这说得通。所以从那以后，在生产链的某个环节上，老实说。
Like we created the baseline for the behavior of each and every user and also for different devices. And we utilize machine learning to identify anomalies in the patterns of behavior of this user and say, oh, wait, this doesn't look like the traditional behavior of that user. That might be an attack. So this is where we use machine learning. Cool. That makes sense. And so then from there, at some point in the chain in production, to be honest.
我认为在过去，我们缺乏合适的工具。所以我们不得不自己构建一切。我们不得不构建某种监控解决方案，而且因为这更像是一堆 Python 脚本而不是一个真正的解决方案，所以我们有 Datadog 之类工具来监控应用程序的工作负载，但我们没有合适的解决方案来跟踪我们的机器学习模型。所以发生了什么？我们只是从客户那里得知了生产环境中的问题，显然，这并不是发现生产环境中问题的好方法。是的，回到你的问题。我只是意识到，越来越多像我们当时那样的公司正在将机器学习用于各种不同的用例。
And I think that back in the day, we were missing out of the proper tooling, right? So we had to build everything ourselves. We had to build kind of a monitoring solution and same kind of because it was more a bunch of Python scripts rather than an actual solution right so we did have beta dog for example to monitor application workloads but we didn't have a proper solution to track our machine learning models so what happened we just learned about issues and productions from our customers which obviously that's not the ideal way to figure out about issues that you have in production. Yeah, so back to your question. I just realized that more and more companies like that we did are utilizing machine learning
而它们所有人都在像我们当年一样，一遍又一遍地编写着完全相同的代码。作为一个软件工程师，我更倾向于代码复用。机器学习监控也是如此。我只是意识到，必须有一个集中式的解决方案，你可以在其中跟踪生产环境中的所有模型，查看它们正在做出什么预测，并自动识别数据漂移或数据完整性问题。
for all sorts of different use cases. And all of them are the same way that we did, are just building again and again the very same code. And as a software engineer, I prefer to do reuse of code, right? So the same goes for ML monitoring. I just realized there has to be one centralized solution where you can track all of your models in production, see what predictions they're making, automatically identify drift or data integrity issues.
所以这正是引导我创立 Aporia 的原因。酷。那么你当时是怎么，怎么说呢，鼓起勇气辞职的呢？你知道，这总是让我感到非常受鼓舞，就像那些说“好吧，你知道，我觉得你不再领那份薪水了，我要寻找自我保障，我要把这个东西做出来并开始获得客户”的人。你是如何下定决心去这么做的？是的。其实我上周末刚和一个朋友见面，讨论的正是这个主题。所以这很有趣，特别是作为一个通常能拿到很不错薪水的工程师，
So that's kind of what led me to live and work in the port. Cool. And so how do you kind of, how do you say this, like muster the courage to quit your job? You know, that's always something I'm really inspired by, like people who say, OK, you know, I feel like you stop getting that paycheck. I'm going to find my self-insurance and I'm going to build this thing out and start getting customers. How did you will yourself to do that? Yeah. Actually, I just met with a friend during the last weekend and discussed this very same subject so it's interesting especially as an engineer where you're getting usually a very nice paycheck
你为什么要辞职去做一些疯狂的事情，甚至可能在没有任何资金的情况下工作一年甚至更长时间？我真的觉得这取决于“你为什么要创办自己的初创公司或自己的公司”这个问题，你的动力是什么。对我来说，这很明确，我真的很想、真的很享受创造。我享受创造产品，我享受组建团队，这才是给我带来快乐的事情，我想产生影响。我相信亲手打造一些属于自己的东西能让你实现这一点。所以这差不多就是我去做的动力。
so why should you quit and go do something crazy and maybe work without any funding for a year or even more than that so I really feel it's the question of why do you want to start your own startup or your own company what's the drive for me it was clear I really wanted I really enjoyed creation I enjoyed
是的，这说得通。我想当你创业时，你创造的东西更多，而且你可以非常专注。我认为，你知道，没有那么多繁文缛节。所以每个人都专注于尽可能快、尽可能多地进行构建。是的，我觉得这其中有些非常令人兴奋的东西。非常酷。所以，是的，这是一个非常了不起的旅程。
creation of products I enjoyed the creation of teams that's what bring me joy and I want to create an impact and I believe that building something of your own allows you to achieve that. So that's kind of what was my drive to go and do that. Yeah, that makes sense. I think you're creating a lot more when you start something and you also can be very focused. I think, you know, there's not as much kind of red tape. So everyone just focus on building as much as they can as quickly as they can. And yeah, I think there's something really exciting about that. Very cool. So yeah, that's an amazing, amazing journey.
我们绝对应该在最后多聊聊 Aporia。我们先给它做个标记，然后跳回主要话题，也就是机器学习工程。那么，什么是机器学习工程师？酷。对于什么是机器学习工程师，有各种各样的描述。如果你在 LinkedIn 上查看公开的职位空缺，你可能会找到不同的描述。但我认为随着时间的推移，
And we should definitely talk more about Aporia at the end. We'll put a bookmark in that and jump to the main topic, which is ML engineering. So what is an ML engineer? Cool. So there are various descriptions to what an ML engineer is. And if you look on LinkedIn for open job positions, you might find different descriptions. But I think as time goes by,
人们对于什么是机器学习工程师已经达成了共识。本质上，机器学习工程师通常是软件工程背景出身的人。他们也可能来自数据科学背景。他们的目标是构建和提供适当的机器学习基础设施，以便能够在生产环境中运行机器学习。这实际上意味着从数据收集开始，比如你如何构建特征存储（Feature Store），以便数据科学家可以就不同的特征进行协作？
there is a consensus about what is machine learning engineer. And essentially, a machine learning engineer is usually someone who's coming from software engineering background. They may also come from data science background. And their purpose is to build and supply proper infrastructure for machine learning that will be able to run machine learning in production. So that really means from data collection, how do you build maybe a feature store so data scientists can collaborate about different features?
你如何为数据科学家构建一个合适的环境来构建他们的模型、尝试不同类型的模型？你如何为他们提供合适的工具来实际打包这些模型、封装它们并将它们部署到生产环境中？最后，你如何让他们能够监控、跟踪生产环境中发生的事情，从而得出见解并进一步改进他们的模型。
How do you build a proper environment for data scientists to build their models, to experiment with different type of models? How you provide them with proper tooling to actually package these models, wrap them up, deploy them to production? And lastly, how do you provide them with proper tooling to actually package these models, wrap them up, deploy them to your production. And lastly, how do you allow them to monitor, track what's going on in production so they can derive insights so they can further improve their models.
所以这实际上是关于机器学习管道的端到端基础设施。这说得通。你可以想象，比如帕特里克从事很多地理空间方面的工作。所以帕特里克可以算作某种地理空间工程师，对吧？但我们其实并没有把它归类为一个独立的职称，对吧？那么，是什么让机器学习工程值得拥有它自己的职称呢？是因为需要大量的技术深度，还是因为机器学习是一个如此巨大的领域？
So it's really about end-to-end infrastructure of the ML pipeline. That makes sense. And so, you know, you can imagine Patrick, for example, does a lot of geospatial work. And so Patrick could be sort of like a geospatial engineer, right? But we don't really go so far as like classify that as its own job title, right? And so what about ML engineering kind of, you know, merits having its own job. Is it the fact that there's so much technical depth required or that ML is such a big space?
是什么将机器学习工程师与任何将东西投入生产的人区分开来？是的。因此，机器学习的工作负载与传统的应用程序工作负载有很大的不同。这就是为什么在机器学习工程方面，你确实需要具备不同的技能组合或经验。你确实需要具备将软件推向生产环境的经验；但你同时也需要对数据科学、机器学习模型及其工作原理有一定的理解。所以我认为这种结合是独一无二的。
What separates ML engineer from somebody who's putting anything in production? Right. So machine learning workloads are very much different than traditional application workloads. And that's why when it comes to ML engineering, yes, you do need to have maybe a different skill set or experience. So you do need to have experience with getting software to production, right? But you also need to have some level of understanding of data science, ML models, how they work. So this kind of combination, I think, is unique.
让它成为一个独立职称的另一个原因——我不，就像我在 Adalon 做这件事的时候，它并不是一个职称，明白吗？所以这是最近几年才有的新事物。我当时只是一个软件架构师。抱歉打断一下，但我有一个疯狂的统计数据。你知道那个吗？我想大概是90%。所以如果你看看所有不同的职称，
And one more reason to make it a title. I don't, like, when I did that at Adelon, it wasn't a title, okay? So it's pretty new from the very last years. I was just a software architect. Sorry to interject, but I have a crazy stat. You know that, I think it's like 90%. So if you look at all the different job titles,
不是每个职称里的人数，而仅仅是职称的数量，其中大约90%都是在过去，我想说是大约20年里创造出来的。这包括了像农民、铁匠之类的所有职业。我想很大一部分原因只是因为环境
so not the people in each title, but just the number of titles, something like 90% of them were created in the past, I want to say like 20 years. And so that includes everything like farmer, blacksmith, you know, like take every profession. And I think a lot of it is just because the landscape
一直在变。类似于爱斯基摩人对冰有100种说法，或者对雪有80种说法之类的，因为他们经常和冰雪打交道，现在他们需要进行区分。好吧，这是用来建冰屋的雪，这是用来化成水的雪，等等。同样地，机器学习工程正在成为一个独立的领域。所以它现在成了另一个职称，这反映了环境变化的速度有多快，以及人工智能和机器学习变得多么重要。是的，基本上，你一针见血地指出，人们在做机器学习工程时需要掌握大量的新技能。你最后可能会得到一个没有任何错误、不会崩溃、没有故障的管道，你的 APM、你的进程监控看起来都很棒。但模型的输出结果简直就是垃圾。
keeps changing. Similar to how, you know, Eskimos have like 100 words for ice or 80 words for snow or something like that, because, you know, they work with it so much and now they need to disambiguate. OK, here's snow that I'm going to use to build an igloo versus here's snow that we're going to use to turn into water, et cetera. You know, similarly, you know, ML engineering is becoming its own field. And so it's now another job title. And, you know, and it reflects kind of just how the landscape keeps changing so quickly and how AI and ML is becoming so important. Yeah, basically, you know, you hit the nail on the head that there's just a ton of new set of skills that folks need to have to do ML engineering. You could end up having a pipeline that doesn't have any errors, it doesn't
所以很显然，有些东西你需要密切关注。这不仅仅是软件健康状况之类的问题。这就是数据科学和统计学背景发挥作用的地方。是的。顺便补充一下，我知道你提到了新职称。所以即使你在 LinkedIn 上看，我上次查的时候，机器学习工程是 LinkedIn 上最抢手、咨询最多的职位。哇。我不知道这个。太疯狂了。是的。所以这挺疯狂的。第二个有趣的事实是，如果你今天去 LinkedIn 上搜索“机器学习工程师”这个职称，你会在美国单独找到大约 14,000 人。
crash, it doesn't, there's no failures, your APM, your process monitoring all looks great. But then the result of the model is just trash, right? And so it's like, clearly, there is something that you need to keep your eye on. That's more than just the sort of software health and all of that. And that's where all of that background in data science and statistics comes in. Yeah. And by the way, just to add on that, I know you mentioned about new titles. So even if you look on LinkedIn, the last time I checked ML engineering was the number one most wanted, most asked for position on LinkedIn. Wow. I didn't know that. That's wild. Yeah. So that's pretty crazy. And the second interesting fact is if you'd go and search for ML engineer title on LinkedIn today, you'd find about 14,000 people in the US alone.
而在六个月前，这个数字是 11,000。所以在那个时间段内增长了大约 30%。所以这相当疯狂。哇，这些数字太震撼了。完全太疯狂了。好吧，那么这里面有没有什么标准化，还是说在人们——不同公司对机器学习工程师职责的理解上——完全是五花八门、各不相同？所以我认为在过去的一年里，对于机器学习工程师在做什么，已经形成了一种相当通用的标准。你会发现，在过去的五六年里，许多公司
Well, six months ago, it was 11,000. So about 30% in that time. So it's pretty crazy. Wow, those numbers are mind blowing. It's totally wild. Okay, so has there been kind of any standardization or is it really all over the place in terms of what people, you know, what different companies think an ML engineer does? So I think that in the last year, there became kind of a pretty much standard for what a machine learning engineer is doing. And what you'll find is that a lot of companies in the past five, six years,
在建立构建机器学习模型的数据科学团队和数据科学小组方面投资了数亿美元。他们意识到的是，为了实现这些家伙的工作成果所带来的影响，他们在拼图里漏掉了一块。而这块缺失的部分就是 MLOps。机器学习工程师正是负责在组织中实际实施 MLOps 的人。所以你会看到，那些顶级科技公司，比如 Netflix、Uber 和 Airbnb，他们构建了自己的内部机器学习平台。
they've been investing over hundreds of millions of dollars in building data science teams and data science groups who are building machine learning models. And what they realized is they're missing a part in the puzzle in order to realize the impact of what these guys are doing. And this missing part is MLOps. And ML engineers are the ones to actually implement MLOps in the organization. So what you'll see, you know, the top tech companies, so companies like Netflix and Uber and Airbnb, they build their internal ML platform.
谁构建了这个平台？机器学习工程师。我们看到的是，越来越多的公司正在聘请机器学习工程师来构建他们的内部机器学习平台。因此，机器学习平台就像是一个中心化的场所，服务于数据科学家的各种需求，使他们能够到达生产环境并妥善管理他们的生产。是的，这说得通。举个例子，讲一个小故事，说明这可能会出多大的问题。是的，我过去在一个研究小组里，那是一家大公司。公司里肯定有机器学习工程师，但我们的研究项目
Who built this platform? The ML engineers. And what we are seeing is that more and more companies are hiring ML engineers to build their internal ML platform. So the ML platform is this kind of centralized place serving all different kind of needs of data scientists to allow them to reach production and to properly manage their production. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, just to show an example, you know, tell a little story of how this can go terribly wrong. Yeah, I was in a research group in the past and it was a huge company. There were definitely ML engineers at the company, but our research project
在公司内部变得非常受欢迎。很多人开始使用它，然后它开始崩溃，接着开始引发这种瀑布效应：我们的研究代码崩溃了，这导致了一大堆其他东西崩溃。然后它最终导致生产环境崩溃，你把原因追溯到了一群写研究论文的书呆子身上。因此，短期解决方案是：好吧，让我们建立一个轮流值班（on-call）制度。但是，我们其实并不知道自己在做什么。我们基本上是研究人员，并不知道如何将任何东西产品化。所以后来，那些真正知道自己在做什么的人
became really popular inside the company. A lot of people started using it and then it started breaking and then it started causing this waterfall effect where our research code would break and that would cause a whole bunch of other things to break. And then it would eventually cause, you know, production to break and you trace it back to a bunch of eggheads who are writing research papers. And so sort of short-term solution was, well, let's just set up an on-call rotation. But, you know, we didn't really know what we were doing. You know, I mean, we were kind of researchers and we didn't know really how to productionize anything. And so then, you know, people who really knew what they were doing,
能够介入并提供帮助。一帮机器学习工程师进来了，把一切都加固了。但在那几个月里确实挺吓人的。是的，这非常有趣。顺便问一下，当有什么东西出问题时，你们是怎么发现的？比如，Dev 或者是 Data Science，或者值班的研究人员，他们是怎么知道出故障的？哦，这是一个好问题。
you know, kind of were able to jump in and help out. And a bunch of ML engineers came in and ruggedized everything. But it was scary for a few months there. Yeah, that's very interesting. And by the way, how did you figure out when something is like, how did Dev on call or Data Science or the researcher on call, how would they know that something got broke down? Oh, that's a great question.
我们做了几件事，其中之一是：当有人训练模型时，如果训练没有成功完成，或者如果当事人因为某种原因提前取消了它，我们会弹出一个简短的插页式问卷调查。类似于：“你为什么要停止这个任务？”所以答案可能是：损失正在失控，或者是用户错误（例如，我自己对构建的东西不满意等）。然后我们就能追踪这一点，
So a number of things that we did, one was when someone trained a model, if the training didn't complete successfully, so if it didn't actually finish or if the person canceled it early for any reason, we put a little interstitial, like a modal survey. It's like, why are you stopping this, this job? And so the answer could be, you know, the loss is spiraling out of control, or it could be a, you know, just user error. You know, control, or it could be, you know, just user error, you know, I didn't like what I built myself, etc. And so that, you know, then we were able to sort of
并努力减少那些说“哦，我停止了这次运行，因为它没有在预期的完成”的人数。我们试图把这个数字降下来。正如我所说，那些真正知道自己在做什么的人进来了，并做了大量的工作。所以我说的只是早期情况不好的时候。这就是程度，后来我转向了另一个研究项目，在那里我们可以尝试追踪一些生产指标，然后发生了一些社交轰动事件。实际上是一只长鹿在动物园里生小宝宝，由于某种原因，这个视频在网上超级火爆。我想它叫……哦，Sophie the giraffe 那个长颈鹿是给小孩子出牙用的玩具。那只长颈鹿有另一个名字。反正就是某种长颈鹿。那只长颈鹿超级火爆。
track that and burn that down number of people who said, Oh, I'm stopping this run, because it never finished when it was supposed to, we tried to get that number down. And as I said, people who really knew what they were doing, came in and did a whole bunch. So I'm only talking about the early days when it was not good. So that's the extent of, then I moved on to some other research project where I could this was we were trying to track you know some production metrics and and some social like sensation went viral it was literally a giraffe was giving birth in a zoo and for whatever reason this went super viral i think it was called no sophie the giraffe is the teething toy for kids. The giraffe had a different name. There's something the giraffe. The giraffe got super viral.
然后突然之间，所有的警报都响了。所有的模型肯定都崩溃了，因为所有的预测表现都远远低于预期。这向我指出，我们需要某种 A/B 测试，我们需要进行缓慢的发布（slow roll），以便我们在任何给定时间都可以拥有两个模型。如果这两个模型都开始产生更多的点击量，那么我们就知道问题出在模型之外。所以，所有这些因果分析、可解释性，这些都是我们当时需要的东西。所以，是的，我想大家后来去构建了很多这样的东西。酷。
Then all of a sudden, everything, all the alerts went off. All the models must be broken because all of the predictions are way underperforming. That pointed out to me that we need some kind of AA testing, you know, we need to have like slow roll so we could have two models at any given time. And if both of those models start generating way more clicks, then we know that, that it's not the model. Right. And so it's all this causal analysis, explainability, but these were all things that we needed. And so, um, yeah, I think folks think folks went on to build a lot of that stuff later. Cool.
是的，我们确实看到越来越多的数据科学和机器学习团队实际上以影子模式（shadow mode）部署模型。因此，他们在生产环境中并行运行同一模型的两个不同实验。这样他们就可以弄清楚哪一个表现更好，然后相应地进行负载均衡，或者进行蓝绿部署，真正尝试多个实验，看看哪个效果更好并相应地进行负载均衡。是的，另一个问题是你在生产中部署的任何东西都会变成一个闭环系统。例如，假设你上 YouTube。有些人去 YouTube 搜索——我这是瞎编的，但模式依然成立——他们搜索“猫”，然后点击第三个视频。他们不是复制那个视频的链接，而是通过这种方式来获取视频：“哦，我搜索‘猫’，然后点击第三个视频，就能得到我想要的这个确切视频。”所以你实际上可以训练另一个模型，参数完全相同，数据完全相同，什么都一样，但仅仅因为随机数和时机等原因，模型就会有所不同。
Yeah, we do see a lot more data science and ML teams actually deploying models either in shadow mode. So they have two different experiments of the same model running in parallel in production. So they can figure out which one is actually overperforming and then do load balancing accordingly and also blue green deployments and really trying to try multiple experiments see what's working better and do load balancing accordingly yep another issue is anything that you deploy in production becomes a closed loop system. So for example, let's say you go on YouTube. There's people who go on YouTube and they search for, I'm just making this up, but the pattern still holds true. They search for cat and they click on the third video. And instead of just
而现在那个视频不再是搜索“猫”的第三个结果了，现在那个模型的表现就会低于预期。所以这就好比你必须应对手中闭环中的所有人及其行为，这使得试图弄清楚你是否真的弄坏了某些东西变得非常困难。是的，还有季节性因素，对吧？比如，我不知道，在过去的几个月里，出于某种原因，人们对猫更感兴趣了。
copying the link to that video, that's their way of getting the video. It's like, oh, I search for cat and I go to the third video and I get this exact video that I want. And so you can actually train another model, exactly same parameters, same data, same everything, but just because of random numbers and timing and stuff, the model will be different. and now that video isn't the third result for cat anymore and now that model underperforms so it's like you have to deal with all the humans that are in the loop too and their behavior and it just became really difficult to try to know if you've actually broken something yeah and there's also the seasonality aspect of things, right? Like maybe, I don't know, in the last few months, people are more interested in cats for some reason.
或者我们即将迎来黑色星期五。所以我想有更多的人想要在亚马逊和其他电子商务网站上购买各种东西。因此，人群的行为正在发生巨大变化。模型还相关吗？
Or we have the upcoming Black Friday. So I guess that a lot of more people are looking to buy all sorts of things on Amazon and other e-commerce websites. So the behavior of the population is changing dramatically. Is the model still relevant? Right.
这是一个非常有趣的问题。是的，我是说，我从来没有为亚马逊工作过，但我100%确信他们有单独的机器学习模型，或者甚至为假期准备了整个机器学习技术栈。或者至少他们有某种残差模型之类的东西。但你是对的。我的意思是，这会把一切都搞得一团糟。我看到的另一个问题是，因为美国的夏令时——我想他们已经取消这个了，对吧，帕特里克？至少在德克萨斯州。哦，在德克萨斯州，我想他们已经取消了。他们很快就会取消它。
It's a very interesting question. Yeah, I mean, I am. I've never worked for Amazon, but I'm 100 percent sure they have a separate machine learning either model or even entire machine learning stack for the holidays. Or at least they have some type of residual model or something. But you're right. I mean, it would throw everything out of whack. I saw another issue where because of daylight savings time in the US, which I think they got rid of this, right, Patrick? At least in Texas. Oh, in Texas, I think they got rid of it. They'll have rid of it soon.
哦，快要取消了吗？是的，还要再过几年。哦，这是全国性的还是只是……？哦，好吧，好吧。所以对于那些不是来自美国的听客，或者其他有这个制度的国家的人来说，我们有这种夏令时，时钟会在春天向前拨快一个小时，然后在秋天向后拨慢一个小时。我想我们会在几年内取消它。但你知道，这意味着有一天你只有23个小时，有一天你有25个小时。每年，我们所有的警报都会在那一天触发。你会少24分之一的点击量之类的。
Oh, it's going to be gone soon? Yeah, it's still a couple more years oh but is that nationally or just yeah oh okay okay so for folks who aren't from the u.s we have this or other countries that have this we have this daylight savings time where the clock jumps forward an hour and then it falls back an hour in the fall um i think we're going to get rid of it in a couple years but but you know that means that there is a day where you only have 23 hours and there's a day where you have 25 hours. And every single year, all of our alarms would fire on that day. You have one 24th less clicks or something.
所以，是的，这些只是机器学习工程师必须处理的一些统计陷阱，这是该职业所独有的。是的，还要处理这些模型需要消耗和处理的大规模数据，有时甚至需要实时处理。所以总之，这里面有各种非常有趣的挑战。有趣的数据工程挑战，有趣的软件工程挑战。所以在我的看法中，这是一个工作起来超级有趣的职业。完全同意。所以通常学术界会稍微落后一点。
So yeah, these are just some of the statistical pitfalls that ML engineers have to deal with that's kind of unique to that profession. Yeah. And also dealing with the large scale of data that these models need to consume and process sometimes even in real time. So all sorts of really interesting challenges, by the way. It's interesting data engineering challenges, interesting software engineering challenges. So I think in my opinion, it's a super interesting profession to work at. Yeah, totally. So usually academia kind of lags behind a little bit.
所以我知道，例如数据科学，在学术界花了好长时间才找到一个数据科学专业，我确信他们现在有了。那么你会对大家有什么建议呢？假设有人在读高中，或者他们只是……依我之见，我的建议是首先获得计算机科学学位，在企业或初创公司获得一些实践经验，但首先要找到你的第一份软件工程师工作。
So I know, for example, data science, it took a long time for you to find a data science program and academia, I'm sure they have them now. So what would you recommend to folks? Let's say someone is in high school or they're just my opinion, my recommendation would be first getting a degree in computer science, getting some hands-on experience in either a corporate or startup company, but just getting your first job as software engineer.
真正亲身体验构建软件、将其投入生产是什么感觉，感受它的成熟度，因为在传统软件中，生产实践非常成熟，这与数据科学不同。然后通过获得这种经验，比如说，花大约一到两年的时间担任软件工程师，然后我认为这将是转型的好时机，也许可以在 Coursera 上选修一些在线课程。
Really feeling hands-on what it feels like to build software, take it to production, feel how mature, because in traditional software, production practices are very much mature, unlike in data science. And then by getting this kind of experience, let's say, spending about one or two years as a software engineer, then I think it could be a good time to transition, maybe take a few courses online in Coursera.
网上有一些非常非常好的数据科学课程，这样你就可以进入这个领域，了解不同类型的机器学习模型，比如决策树、回归和神经网络，以及它们之间的区别是什么。从那里，真正过渡到你现有的公司内部，或者寻找一份机器学习工程师的工作。因为这个角色本身相当新颖，它是在
There are some really, really good courses online for data science, so you can get into that field, understand different types of machine learning models, you know, decision trees and regression and neural nets and what's the difference between all of them. And from there, really transition either within your existing company or just look for a job as an ML engineer. Because the role itself is pretty much new, it just was introduced
过去一年才引入的，公司很难找到具有机器学习工程以往经验的人。因此，拥有软件工程加上对数据科学的一些知识或经验是一个巨大的优势。这说得通。所以我想大多数人——我们做过无数关于如何成为软件工程师的节目。我们真的没有做过关于如何成为数据科学家的节目。那么人们是如何建立——我们讨论了很多关于所有这些有趣的统计问题以及如何试图从中提取因果关系。是的，人们是如何获得这方面的经验的？是去上一些统计学课程吗？是看 YouTube 吗？你是在哪里学习你的数据科学核心知识的？
in the last year, it will be difficult for companies to find someone with past experience in ML engineering, right? So having software engineering plus some knowledge or experience with data science is a huge advantage. Yeah, that makes sense. So I think most folks, we've done tons of shows on how to be a software engineer. We've never really done a show on how to be a data scientist. So how do people build, we talked a lot about all these statistical funny things that can happen and how to try to pull causality out of that yeah how do people get experience in that is it is it taking some stats classes is it is it youtube but where did you learn um kind of your your data science core so
我确实学习了我的数据科学核心知识，其中一部分是在某些学术课程中完成的。这其实是在我上高中时。但话说回来，在我攻读学位期间，那是我获得至少开始进行这项工作所需的大部分理论知识的地方。你知道，本质上，你只需使用一些 Python 库，
i did learn my data science core part of it was in some academic program. This was actually while at high school. But then again, while doing my measure, that's where I got most of, at least the theoretical knowledge that I had to have in order to start doing that. You know, essentially, you can just take some Python library,
比如你可以使用 XGBoost 来训练你的模型，你大概就能训练并构建出一个模型。但你无法真正理解如何做出一个好模型。你需要对不同的超参数有很好的理解，明白什么是 alpha，什么是 learning rate。所以你必须获得这些理论知识。因此，依我之见，为了成为一名优秀的数据科学家，你至少必须具备理论背景。我想你在行业中会看到很多拥有硕士和博士学位的人
you can take XGBoost, for example, and train your model, and you probably will be able to train and build a model. But you won't be able to really understand how to make a good model. You need to have a good understanding of different hyperparameters and what alpha means and what learning rate means. So you have to get this theoretical knowledge. So in my opinion, in order to become a good data scientist, you have to come from a theoretical background, at least. I think what you'll see in the industry is a lot of people with masters and PhDs
担任数据科学家。我认为随着时间推移这正在改变。但至少这是我所看到的。是的，这说得通。Liran，你是在哪里学习的？你不是在美国学习的吧？不是的，我没有。好的。
as data scientists. And I think it is changing over time. But at least that's what I'm seeing. Yeah, I think that makes sense. So Liran, did you study, you didn't study in the US or did you? No, I did not. Okay.
我在以色列学习的。我觉得我们的统计学，即使对工程师来说也不是很好。我想，帕特里克，你上过针对工程师的统计学吗？或者你们学校是怎么安排的？你是去佛罗里达大学（UF）对吧？是的，我们只有一门基础统计学课。那是面向所有人的一节巨型阶梯教室大课，数学、工程学等等都在一起。就是这样。
And I studied in Israel. I feel like our statistics, even for engineers is not good. I think, Patrick, did you take statistics for engineers or how did that work at your school? You went to UF, right? Yeah, we had like, just a single basic statistics class. There was like a giant auditorium class across everyone, math, engineering, all of that. That was it.
我在以色列学习过。我觉得我们的统计学，即使对工程师来说，也学得不够好。帕特里克，我想问你，你上过工程统计学吗？或者你们学校是怎么安排的？你是去弗罗里达大学对吧？对，我们只有一门基础统计学课程。那是一个面向所有人（包括数学、工程等专业）的大型阶梯教室大课，就这些。
We had the same thing. And so I was in this cohort of people who could apply early, like who could get first dibs on the classes, which is super convenient, loved it. But I happened to pick this and I learned my lesson. This was first year. I picked this statistics class and it was almost empty. It was at a really convenient time where I lived really far from the university. So I could, if I picked this particular statistics class, I would only have to go to the university
我们也有过同样的经历。当时我和一群人一起，我们可以提前申请，也就是能优先选课，这非常方便，我超喜欢。但我偏偏选了这个，结果吃一堑长一智。那是大一的时候。我选了一门统计学课，几乎没人。上课时间非常合适，因为我住得离学校很远。如果我选这门特定的统计学课，我每周就只需要去学校
two days a week. I could just go and do all my courses. And then the other two days I could stay at home and just do homework or whatever. And so I picked that stats class. It was almost empty when I picked it, which really, almost full, sorry, when I picked it, which really surprised me. It turns out that was the stats class for all the professional athletes. So if you were effectively majoring in scoring touchdowns or something, like your coach told you, take this statistics class.
两天。我可以去上完所有的课。另外两天我可以待在家写作业或者干别的。所以我选了那门统计学课。我选课时发现它几乎没人，不，抱歉，我选的时候几乎已经坐满了，这让我非常吃惊。原来那是所有专业运动员上的统计学课。所以如果你当时的专业基本上是拿达阵得分之类的，你的教练就会告诉你，去选这门统计学课。
And I don't know if I'm like as a big expose on the academic industrial complex or something, but I walked into this class. At one point, the teacher was like, ask this super basic question. Like how many ways could you pick two things from four things or something? And this person says 23. And he's like, why did you say 23? He's like, cause it's Michael Jordan's number. Yeah. It's just like, oh my God, what am I, what have I done? This is like my first college experience. I was, I probably should have got into industry. Uh, I definitely felt that way at the moment, but that was, that was it. Like that was all the statistics courses that we had in undergrad. And so I, I guess, uh, you know, maybe now it's a lot better, but, but I implore folks to, uh, you know, take, uh, some other statistics classes as electives if you can,
我不知道这算不算揭露学术工业复合体之类的黑幕，但当我走进去这堂课时。有一次，老师问了一个超级基础的问题。比如从四个东西里选两个有多少种方法之类的。这个人回答23。老师问，你为什么说23？他说，因为这是迈克尔·乔丹的球号。好吧，我当时就想，天哪，我这是在干什么，我都干了些什么？这简直是我大学的初体验。我当时可能应该直接去工作的，嗯，我当时确实有这种感觉，但这，这就是我们本科上的所有统计学课程了。所以，我想，你知道，也许现在情况好多了，但我恳求大家，如果可以的话，去选修一些其他的统计学课程，
because it's by far the most important thing that you'll use as an engineer yeah and i think today there are so many things online right so even if you end up in such a statistics fun fun statistics course like you just had right you can still complement that by learning on your own in your free time if you have such you know getting some more knowledge more experience actually i there is a university in Israel that has, that's actually how I learned statistics. I don't remember the name of the university. It was a long time ago, but they had a YouTube channel and they had a bunch of statistics courses and they have game theory courses there too. I mean, now I don't know if that's even a good recommendation because it's like 15 years old or something.
因为这是你作为工程师会用到的、迄今为止最重要的东西。没错，而且我觉得现在网上的资源太多了，所以即使你最终陷入了这样一个有趣的统计学课程，就像你刚才经历的那样，如果你有这种想法，你仍然可以通过在空闲时间自学来作为补充，获取更多的知识、更多的经验。其实，以色列有一所大学，我就是那样学统计学的。我不记得那所大学的名字了。那是很久以前的事了，但他们有一个YouTube频道，上面有很多统计学课程，那里还有博弈论课程。我是说，现在我不知道这算不算是一个好建议，因为那已经是大约15年前的事了。
But yeah, there's a bunch of amazing resources online. And you can build yourself up. And you can go at your own pace too. So if there's something that clicks right away, you just skip it. And if there's something you don't understand, you can watch it as many times as you want. You can watch three different professors you know give you three different takes on the same thing yeah actually one of the most popular ones is a course by
不过是的，网上有很多了不起的资源。你可以自我提升。而且你也可以按照自己的节奏学习。所以如果有哪个知识点你一听就懂，你就可以直接跳过。如果有不懂的地方，你想看多少遍都可以。你可以看三个不同的教授，你知道的，对同一件事情给出三种不同的看法。是的，事实上，最受欢迎的课程之一来自
from stanford i'm not saying anything new it's like i think maybe it's the most popular course in coursera but this is highly recommended yep yeah totally yeah no matter how many courses you take though at least my courses i'll take i will never figure out like eigenvectors and eigenvalues like that will always occupy some part of my brain that i can't totally access but maybe maybe your odds will be different but at least you can try as many times as you want so yeah that's true you can do replay yeah andrew ring's course is phenomenal. Yeah, highly recommend it. I don't know if he's doing new ones.
斯坦福大学。我这话没有新意，我觉得这可能是Coursera上最受欢迎的课程，但这真的极力推荐。对，完全同意。不管你上了多少门课，至少对我上的课来说，我永远也搞不懂特征向量和特征值——这永远会占据我大脑的一部分，让我无法完全理解，但也许，也许你的运气会不同，但至少你可以随心所欲地尝试多少次都可以，所以是的，这是真的，你可以反复观看。没错，吴恩达的课太棒了。是的，强烈推荐。我不知道他现在有没有出新课。
I know he has, I think it's like deeplearning.ai is his domain. And he might have new content there. But his original course is fantastic. So what are kind of, you know, different, like, do you have any sort of ML engineering horror stories? Other than the ones I told, but do you have any of your own, like things that, you know, kind of went terribly wrong that could kind of give people insight into what that's like and how to recover from that and excel from that? Oh, yeah.
我知道他有一个域名，好像是deeplearning.ai。他可能在那里有新内容。但他最初的那门课棒极了。那么，有什么不同寻常的，比如说，你有什么机器学习工程方面的恐怖故事吗？除了我讲的那些，你有没有自己经历过的，比如哪些事情搞得一团糟，能让人了解那种情况是什么样的，以及如何从中恢复并脱颖而出？哦，有啊。
Well, there are plenty of them, right? A lot of time it happened to me that you know we we used to work on a model it was functioning very very well on training and when we tested it and it seemed to be working fine we deployed it to production at the beginning everything seemed to be working working fine as well and a few weeks go by, and then we got starting. And then I'm talking about previous company. We started getting some questions from our product teams, from our clients.
嗯，有很多这样的事，对吧？很多时候我经历过这样的情况：我们曾经开发过一个模型，它在训练时运行得非常好，当我们测试它时，它似乎也工作正常，于是我们将它部署到了生产环境中。一开始，一切似乎也都运行正常，几周过去了，然后我们开始收到。我是说上一家公司。我们开始收到来自产品团队、来自客户的一些问题。
And the assumption was that something wrong with the models. It's always the assumption, by the way. Yeah, that's right. And we went and really investigated what has changed, if something has changed with our model, with our data. And what we realized is we didn't do anything wrong. It was just someone else in a different software engine, the backend team, that changed some logic
大家的假设是模型出了问题。顺便说一句，这总是人们的第一假设。是的，确实如此。于是我们去深入调查了到底发生了什么变化，模型或数据是否有变。而我们意识到的是，我们没做错任何事。只是其他团队的某个人，在不同的软件引擎、后端团队中，修改了一些逻辑，
to the fact that the data that got to our model, and as a result, it completely changed the behavior of our model. Right? So it wasn't even our fault but it happened so many times and it's so frustrating yeah actually that's a good segue into into training serving uh skew and just training serving in general like uh we talked about matlab and and know, people might write a Python program and a Python program is full of Python for loops and it takes forever. And, you know, how do they get that model? How do you get some research code into production? And then, you know, how do you iterate back and forth, right? The researcher,
导致流入我们模型的数据发生了变化，结果完全改变了我们的模型行为。对吧？所以这甚至不是我们的错，但这种情况发生过太多次了，实在太令人沮丧了。其实，这很好地过渡到了训练服务偏移（training-serving skew）以及一般的训练和部署话题。就像我们谈到Matlab时，人们可能会写一个Python程序，而Python程序里充满了Python的for循环，运行慢得要命。然后，你知道，他们是如何得到那个模型的？你是如何将一些研究代码投入生产环境的？然后，你知道，你又是如何在其中来回迭代的呢？研究员，
you know, how do you keep that latency kind of low? Yeah, so how do you get models into production? I think this is a huge question. A lot of companies are trying to figure out now, how do they get more models into production? And that is exactly where machine learning engineering comes to place. How do you create proper infrastructure so data scientists can release ml models more easily and more
你知道，你如何保持这种低延迟？是的，那么你如何将模型投入生产环境呢？我认为这是一个巨大的问题。许多公司现在都在试图弄清楚，他们如何才能将更多的模型投入生产环境？这正是机器学习工程发挥作用的地方。你如何建立合适的infrastructure（基础设施），以便数据科学家能够更轻松、更频繁地将ml模型发布
frequently through production so i think that in the past we used to see some teams where the data scientists would package their modeling to a pico file they would hand over to a software engineer from a different team, and they will kind of rewrite it in a different language. So instead of Python, it will be rewritten in Java, for example, and that's what will be run in production. That doesn't work very well, right? Because all this translation from one language to another, huge opportunity for a lot of bugs.
到生产环境中？所以我觉得过去我们经常看到一些团队，数据科学家会将他们的模型打包成一个pico文件，然后交由不同团队的软件工程师，他们会用另一种语言重写一遍。比如不用Python，而是用Java重写，而这就是将在生产环境中运行的东西。这效果其实不太好，对吧？因为所有这些从一种语言到另一种语言的翻译，都带来了大量产生bug的机会。
So I think today they're pretty much good tooling and good open source tools for packaging, like Bento ML, for example, is a cool open source that allows you to package your model and ship them to production. Now, how does that work? So if you're writing in Python, what does your production environment look like and how does BentoML get you there?
所以我想现在有很多相当不错的工具和开源工具用于打包，比如BentoML就是一个很酷的开源工具，它允许你打包模型并将其发布到生产环境。那么，这是如何运作的呢？如果你用Python编写，你的生产环境是什么样的，BentoML又是如何带你实现这一点的？
Yeah, so I'll talk in general, like there's BentoML and Kubeflow and other solution, but per your question, kind of how do you scale it up? I think the main way to do it is by leveraging Kubernetes and Docker. So what you'd usually do is you'll build a service around your machine learning model, and that service will expose a REST API endpoint or GraphQL endpoint to the machine learning model, for example, to the predict function.
是的，我先概括一下，有BentoML、Kubeflow和其他解决方案，但针对你的问题，关于如何扩展它？我认为实现这一目标的主要方法是利用Kubernetes和Docker。所以你通常要做的是围绕你的机器学习模型构建一个服务，该服务将向机器学习模型公开一个REST API端点或GraphQL端点，例如针对predict（预测）函数。
And then you run this service on top of Kubernetes so you can scale it horizontally. Yeah, that makes sense. So if you're going to do that, actually, you could run Python then in production. I mean, it might not be as fast as C or something, but I mean, you just add more nodes and it won't be orders of magnitude slower. Oh, yeah, you can definitely run Python in production with Python free for sure. And to be honest, because of all the libraries that are existing today in Python, Pandas, NumPy, PySpark, you have so many libraries to process a lot of data very, very efficiently. Usually it will be more efficient than just rewriting it yourself in another language. So if you wanna run models in production, unless you have some specific constraints,
然后你在Kubernetes之上运行这个服务，这样你就可以横向扩展它。是的，这说得通。所以如果你要这么做，实际上你就可以在生产环境里运行Python了。我是说，它可能没有C语言那么快，但我的意思是，你只需要增加更多的节点，它就不会慢上几个数量级。哦，是的，你绝对可以用Python 3在生产环境中运行Python。说实话，由于目前Python中存在的各种库——Pandas、NumPy、PySpark，你有如此多的库可以非常非常高效地处理大量数据。通常这会比你自己用另一种语言重写更有效率。所以如果你想在生产环境中运行模型，除非你有某些特定的限制，
yes, Python would usually be the main go-to. Got it, that makes sense. And so I think then the biggest challenge becomes when you are loading the data at training, right? You need to load in like huge volumes of this data that's like frozen in place, like you have a data lake, like s3, or one of these things, and you're just streaming in just huge volumes of data and iterating your model. But then at serving time, it's totally different, right at serving time, like maybe you're getting an SMS or something,
是的，Python通常会是首选。明白了，这说得通。所以我想最大的挑战在于你在训练时加载数据的时候，对吧？你需要加载海量的、静止不动的数据，就像你有一个数据湖，比如S3或诸如此类的东西，然后你只是源源不断地流式传输海量数据并迭代你的模型。但到了服务时，情况就完全不同了，在服务时，可能你会收到一条短信之类的，
and that SMS needs to get turned into into a piece of data that then goes into your model. And so how do you keep those homogeneous? Yeah, so I'd say it's a case by case. It's a very interesting question. How do you scale this up from running your models in training where in a way you run it in batch versus... So in general, we split the type of machine learning models to batch models. For example, they might be running once a week. And then they'll be getting like millions of predictions
而这条短信需要变成一段数据，然后输入到你的模型中。那么你如何保持它们的一致性呢？是的，所以我想这要具体情况具体分析。这是一个非常有趣的问题。你如何将它从训练时的模型运行（某种程度上你是按批次运行的）扩展开来……所以一般来说，我们将机器学习模型的类型分为批处理模型。例如，它们可能一周运行一次。然后它们会获得数百万个预测，
in the same time. Node type is near real time. And then you have the last part, which is real time. For example, if you're i know a master card or visa or amex right and they're checking your transactions for fraud that means that whenever you swipe your card a machine learning model is running and evaluating whether this is fraud now that has to be in a millisecond's time actually that's interesting you know you're kind of bringing up something that i hadn't really thought about, which is like, you could build a machine. So
同时进行。另一种类型是近实时。最后一部分是实时。例如，如果你是——我知道的，万事达卡、维萨卡或美国运通卡——他们在检查你的交易是否存在欺诈，这意味着每当你刷卡时，机器学习模型都在运行并评估这是否是欺诈。这必须在毫秒级别内完成。其实这很有趣，你提出了一点我之前没怎么想过的事情，那就是：你可以构建一个机器学习……
MasterCard, using your example, they could build a machine learning model offline that kind of says, if I see this type of person in the future, then it's fraud. And if I see this type of person, it's not fraud. And then the model can be just frozen and say, you know, if it sees a new person it hasn't seen before, it still can follow the same formula. Say like, okay, this person, I'm going to break them down into some history, process this history and say, yes, it's fraud. Or like alternatively, the model itself can run, can update in real time. It's not clear to me like when to use one or the other.
以万事达卡为例，他们可以离线构建一个机器学习模型，该模型大意是：如果我以后看到这种类型的人，那么这就是欺诈；如果我看到那种类型的人，这就不是欺诈。然后模型可以被冻结，并说，你知道，如果它看到一个以前没见过的新人，它仍然可以遵循相同的公式。比如，好吧这个人，我要把他的行为拆解成一些历史数据，处理这些历史数据，然后说，是的，这是欺诈。或者另一种选择是，模型本身可以运行，可以实时更新。我不太清楚什么时候该用哪种。
I guess you could have a model that just describes all these different archetypes of people and then it doesn't have to update in real time. The data is kind of updating in real time. So yeah, can you walk me through like that whole paradigm? Like when would you train a model in real time? And how would that even work? So what you're talking about is the concept of auto-retraining,
我想你可以有一个模型，它只是描述了所有这些不同类型的人，然后它就不需要实时更新了。数据在某种程度上是实时更新的。所以，是的，你能给我梳理一下整个范式吗？什么时候你会实时训练一个模型？这又该如何运作呢？你所谈论的是自动重新训练（auto-retraining）的概念，
like automatically retraining your model upon new data that got to production, automatically releasing it to production so it can leverage the newly deployed model. So it is possible to do it. My recommendation is if you're going that route, you have to have a lot of automated tests to your data and to your model before you release it to production automatically. It's kind of best practice in general, by the way, to retrain your model every now and then. Because if you'll think about it, when you train a model, you train it on a specific snapshot of reality, right?
就像根据到达生产环境的新数据自动重新训练你的模型，并自动将其发布到生产环境，以便它能够利用新部署的模型一样。这样做是可行的。我的建议是，如果你走这条路，在自动发布到生产环境之前，你必须对数据和模型进行大量的自动化测试。顺便说一句，定期重新训练模型通常是最佳实践。因为如果你仔细想想，当你训练一个模型时，你是在现实的一个特定快照上训练它的，对吧？
It might be like the last five years of loan applications or credit card transactions. But reality is constantly changing, right? We had COVID, now we have the holidays upcoming. A lot of things are constantly changing. So we need to make sure that our models are updating themselves to the new reality. So that's why, in general, it's a good practice to do retraining every now and then. But also, when doing retraining, you have to watch what data you're using for retraining.
它可能是过去五年的贷款申请或信用卡交易。但现实是在不断变化的，对吧？我们经历过新冠疫情，现在假期又要来了。很多事情都在不断变化。因此，我们需要确保我们的模型能够自我更新以适应新的现实。这就是为什么总的来说，定期进行重新训练是一个好习惯。但是，在进行重新训练时，你也必须注意你用于重新训练的数据。
Because if there is malfunction with the data, for example, maybe there was an outage of some data. So you got a lot of now values as part of your, let's say, just 5% of your data points. And when we are talking about millions or even billions of records, you might not notice that. But for the model, it might learn something wrong. A behavior that you don't want it to learn. So that's why on one hand, I'm saying retraining is important and you have to do it
因为如果数据出现故障，例如，可能某些数据中断了。所以你现在作为数据的一部分得到了很多空值（null values），比方说占了你数据点的5%。而当我们谈论数百万甚至数十亿条记录时，你可能不会注意到这一点。但对于模型来说，它可能会学到错误的东西。学到你不希望它学习的行为。这就是为什么一方面，我说重新训练很重要，你必须这样做，
every now and then. But with that, I'm saying automatic retraining could also be dangerous if not done properly with proper tooling and measures. Yeah, that makes sense. That totally makes sense. Yeah, I feel like most people probably don't need real time. So most people don't need automatic retrading that's done every minute, or every hour or something like that. That seems overkill. For a lot of things, it seems like that might be a better place to have sort of some data or some counters that are updating in real time. the model doesn't have to be so much real time yeah and training might also be very expensive and so your question beforehand about how do you decide whether you should retrain the data like train a model for each specific person or have this one huge model for tons of transactions and just retrain. So these are kind of architectural decisions. This is why it's so important to understand the inner depth of how these machine learning models are working behind the scenes, how these algorithms are working, how the accurate
每隔一段时间。但与此同时，我也说过，如果不配合适当的工具和措施，妥善处理，自动重新训练也可能是危险的。是的，这说得通。完全说得通。是的，我觉得大多数人可能并不需要实时。所以大多数人并不需要每分钟或每小时进行一次自动重新训练之类的。那似乎有点小题大做了。对于很多事情来说，似乎更好的做法是拥有一些实时更新的数据或计数器，而模型不需要那么实时。是的，而且训练也可能非常昂贵，所以你之前的问题是关于如何决定是应该为每个人重新训练数据——为每个特定人训练一个模型，还是为一个海量的交易拥有一个庞大的模型然后只是重新训练。所以这些都是架构决策。这就是为什么理解这些机器学习模型在幕后如何运作的内在深度、这些算法如何运作、精确的参数如何影响最终生成的模型是如此重要。
parameters affect the end resulting model. So you can make the right decision when thinking about this architecture. Yeah, that makes sense. So for folks who are, let's say, let's kind of role play here that we're hiring for a ML engineer. What would that resume look like? I mean, what kind of, we talked about definitely,
这样当你在考虑这个架构时，你就能做出正确的决定。是的，这说得通。所以对于那些，比方说，我们在这里角色扮演一下，我们正在招聘一名机器学习工程师。那简历会是什么样的？我的意思是，我们讨论过肯定，
you know, it's good to get an advanced degree. You know, you get hit much harder with stats and these other things in your master's and your doctorate. But beyond academics, what are other things you look for in a resume of an ML engineer if you're hiring one? So definitely experience in software engineering and delivering software to production. That will be very important.
你知道，获得高级学位很好。在你的硕士和博士学位中，你会受到统计学和其他这些东西的严厉洗礼。但除了学术之外，如果你在招聘的话，你在机器学习工程师的简历中还会寻找哪些其他东西？绝对是软件 engineering（工程）的经验，以及将软件交付到生产环境的经验。这将非常重要。
And especially when today a lot of time, because machine learning is a new practice, it's all about building something from scratch, right? And I like to say that time spent planning is time well spent. So in order to build the proper ML engineering pipeline and a proper ML platform, doing the right planning and the right design and architecture from the very beginning is crucial. You don't want to be in one year ahead and realizing, oh, we made a bad architecture decision. We need to refactor or even rewrite our ML platform or part of it.
特别是现在很多时候，由于机器学习是一门新兴的实践，一切都是从零开始构建的，对吧？我经常说，花在规划上的时间就是节省下来的时间。因此，为了构建合适的机器学习工程流水线和平台，从一开始就进行正确的规划、设计和架构至关重要。你绝对不想在一年后才意识到，噢，我们做出了一个糟糕的架构决定，我们需要重构甚至重写我们的机器学习平台或其一部分。
So that's why having experience in writing, designing software, architecting software, I think is a key part in being a good ML engineer. Yeah, that makes sense. I think the nice thing about that too is, you know, ML engineer builds on top of a lot of other building blocks. And so if someone's just getting started, it might be hard for somebody to know. It's like, you know, everyone says,
这就是为什么拥有编写、设计和架构软件的经验，我认为是成为一名优秀的机器学习工程师的关键部分。是的，这很有道理。我觉得这样做的好处还在于，机器学习工程师是建立在许多其他基础之上的。所以如果有人刚开始入门，可能会很难搞清楚。就像每个人都说的那样，
my kids want to be astronauts when they grow up. None of them say, I want to be a machine learning engineer when I grow up, right? Maybe a software engineer. But so this is like something where, you know, you can build those foundations. If you love building software, you like solving, you know, kind of different kind of mathematical challenges at your company.
我的孩子们长大后想成为宇航员。没有人会说，我长大后想成为一名机器学习工程师，对吧？也许会说软件工程师。但这正是你可以打下那些基础的地方。如果你热爱构建软件，如果你喜欢在公司里解决各种不同类型的数学挑战，
How do we capture this value accurately? I have a buddy who worked for what's the company that Groupon Groupon that does this like, you know, I guess Internet coupon type thing. And this was pretty early. So they were just kind of getting started. And they had this issue where they wanted to kind of predict how many coupons are going to sell before, you know, before they air this merchant, right? They wanted to know, okay, is this merchant going to do well on Groupon before we give them a platform, right? And so this, again, very early in Groupon, this friend of mine, just pure software engineer, but he was kind of faced with this sort of statistical or challenge or his predictive
我们如何准确地捕获这个价值？我有一个朋友在 Groupon 工作，就是那个做互联网优惠券的公司。当时这还很早期，所以他们刚开始起步。他们遇到了这样一个问题：他们想在向这个商家投放之前，预测会卖出多少优惠券。他们想知道，在我们给他们平台之前，这个商家在 Groupon 上会表现得好吗？在 Groupon 的早期，我的这位朋友仅仅是一名纯粹的软件工程师，但他面临着这种统计学上的挑战或预测挑战，
challenge and went on and built a lot of those skills and then got really interested in ML and AI and lot of those skills and then got really interested in ML and AI and all of that. And so I think that's a good, really good advice, Liram, is, you know, folks out there just get started by building cool stuff. And when you build anything, you will always reach some point where you need to predict something. If nothing else, you need to predict how many people are using that, how many people are going to use that thing you built, right? Everyone's going to need to predict that. So yeah, building stuff is a good gateway to having to do stats. And that's a gateway to ML engineering. Yeah, that's a good summary of it. Yeah. So how would you decide whether you want to be an ML engineer or data scientist before you start your studies.
然后他掌握了许多这方面的技能，并对机器学习和人工智能产生了浓厚的兴趣。所以我认为这是一个非常好的建议，利拉姆（Liram），大家可以从构建有趣的东西开始入手。当你构建任何东西时，你总是会到达某个你需要进行预测的点。如果别的不用预测，你至少需要预测有多少人在使用它，有多少人会使用你构建的东西，对吧？每个人都需要预测这一点。所以，构建东西是通往统计学的一个良好途径，而这也是通往机器学习工程的途径。是的，这是一个很好的总结。那么，在开始学习之前，你将如何决定自己是想成为一名机器学习工程师还是数据科学家呢？
And I think that maybe after studies, it's a question of what kind of person are you? Do you enjoy more doing research or do you enjoy more developing? Do you get excited about digging into data and playing around with different parameters and thinking about algorithms? Is that kind of what excites you? Or are you more excited about software architecture and this kind of thing? So it's very different, in my opinion. And based on these questions, you can identify whether you're more data scientist
我想也许在学习之后，问题就在于你是怎样的人？你更享受做研究，还是更享受开发？你是否对深入研究数据、摆弄不同的参数以及思考算法感到兴奋？这就是让你兴奋的事情吗？还是说你对软件架构这类东西更感兴趣？在我看来，这两者非常不同。根据这些问题，你可以确定自己更适合成为数据科学家
or more of a software engineer. For example, if you do a project, like you mentioned, predicting how many users are going to sign up, right? Or something like that. Which parts of this project do you enjoy more? Do you enjoy more conducting the research and optimizing the algorithm
还是软件工程师。例如，如果你做一个项目，就像你提到的那样，预测有多少用户会注册，对吧？或者类似的事情。这个项目的哪些部分你更喜欢？你更喜欢进行研究和优化算法，
and squeezing one you know one more percent inaccuracy is that kind of what drives you or you you're crazy about how do you think about the class architecture the classes architecture and this kind of thing the microservices so it's two different things yeah Yeah, that makes sense. Well, would you agree with that? Like, you know, you being a researcher? Yeah, I think you hit that on the head. So, you know, I got into this through my PhD, which was on games, playing games with AI. And so we would do a lot of different sort of ways of improving the system. A lot of it was through self-play, but then we would have other agents that you could play against. So for example, we were doing chess, you know, we would
并且把准确率再挤出一两个百分点，这就是驱动你的动力吗？还是说你对类架构、类的架构以及诸如此类的微服务疯狂着迷？所以这是两码事。是的，这很有道理。你会同意这一点吗？比如，你作为一名研究员？是的，我认为你切中要害了。我进入这个领域是通过我的博士学位，研究方向是游戏，即用人工智能玩游戏。所以我们会做许多不同类型的方法来改进系统。很大一部分是通过自我对弈，但我们也会有其他可以与之对战的智能体。例如，我们在研究国际象棋时，
play against GNU chess and see how many levels of GNU chess we could beat with what we were doing, right? And then with Go, there were open source programs that were pretty good. And you could also run those for longer. You could kind of cheat on their behalf, right? So you could kind of make it the domain more difficult. And so the exciting part was, you know, how good can we get this? You know, can we make a world champion level player? And what's the ELO of this chess player?
会与 GNU 国际象棋对战，看看我们做出的系统能击败多少级别的 GNU 国际象棋，对吧？然后对于围棋，有一些相当不错的开源程序。你也可以让它们运行更长时间。你可以替它们作弊，对吧？所以你可以让领域变得更困难。令人兴奋的部分是，我们可以把系统做到多好？我们能创造出一个世界冠军级别的玩家吗？这个国际象棋玩家的 ELO 评分是多少？
And how could we get a chess player to be better and better without more work like without more human work you know just by spending computer time how can we like what's the limit there this was i got my phd around 2009 so at this point like uh to answer that question you know we had to write a zillion lines of code. I think it was all C++, which is super painful. But I think that, you know, that was in service of trying to get that, you know, synthetic ELO as high as possible. So you're always kind of looking at that number and saying, can I do better there? So yeah, I think you hit the nail on the head.
我们如何在不需要更多人工工作的情况下，仅仅通过消耗计算机时间，让国际象棋玩家变得越来越好？极限在哪里？我是在 2009 年左右获得博士学位的，所以当时为了回答这个问题，我们不得不编写无数行的代码。我想全部都是 C++，这非常痛苦。但我认为，那是为了尽可能提高那个合成 ELO 评分服务的。所以你总是看着那个数字，然后问自己，我能做得更好吗？所以是的，我觉得你切中要害了。
I think data scientists look at, you know, can I either, you know, predict this thing more accurately than I did the day before? Or can I make this number go either as high or as low as I want? So the lowest amount of, you know, spam, the highest amount of revenue, and what is going to cause this to go up. And on the software side, you know, I think there is something really satisfying about building something that's really clean, that scales. There's that feeling where you've ever kind of ported one thing from one platform to another. And the first time you run it, there's a zillion errors. And then you go through and get it down to zero, and then it works. I mean, that's extremely rewarding. So I think those are kind of the two different dynamics there. Yeah, I agree. Yeah, I think now there is some,
我认为数据科学家关注的是：我能否比前一天更准确地预测这个东西？或者我能否让这个数字达到我想要的最高或最低值？垃圾邮件最少，收入最高，是什么原因让这个数字上升。而在软件方面，我认为构建真正干净、可扩展的东西确实有一种极大的满足感。那种你曾经把一个东西从一个平台移植到另一个平台的感觉，当你第一次运行它时，有无数的错误。然后你一步步排查，把错误降到零，最后它成功运行了。我的意思是，这极具成就感。所以我认为这是两种不同的动力。是的，我同意。是的，我认为现在还有一些，
there's still, I think, a decent amount of C++, but maybe it doesn't need to be. It's kind of, like nowadays, you know, unless you're doing some stock trading or one of these things, you can just get it done with Python. So I really like C++. I know it's not something to be proud of. What do you think of these C++ replacements, like Rust and Carbon and these other languages? So I really like C++ for various reasons. I don't think that C++ is a good language for most of the use cases and most of the projects or software today. I just enjoy
我觉得 C++ 的数量仍然相当可观，但也许它不一定非得是 C++。现在，除非你在做股票交易或类似的事情，否则用 Python 就能搞定。我真的很喜欢 C++。我知道这没什么好骄傲的。你如何看待这些 C++ 的替代品，比如 Rust、Carbon 和其他这些语言？我出于各种原因真的很喜欢 C++。我不认为 C++ 是当今大多数用例、项目或软件的好语言。我只是非常喜欢它，
it very much and that was kind of my first language that I learned very, very to the deep of how everything works behind the scenes in C++. And things are very complex behind the scenes in C++. And that's part of the reason I don't think it's a very good language today.
那是我的第一门编程语言，我非常深入地学习了 C++ 底层是如何工作的。C++ 的底层非常复杂，这也是我认为它今天不再是一门好语言的部分原因。
Yeah, I think that you can kind of shoot yourself in the foot with like pound defines and templates and some of these things. Even just when creating a new object, a constructor could fail, for example. It's not obvious. Yep, yep, yep. Yeah, I think that a lot of people use templates when really they need to use other design patterns. And I think the problem with that is once you use a template in C++, everyone else has to start using it too. And so, and so it, because of the way the specialization works, all of that, you end up in this mess. Like when I saw, for example, oh yeah, here's a good example. You might say, I want to have a synthetic clock.
是的，我觉得你可以用宏定义（pound defines）、模板以及诸如此类的东西来搬起石头砸自己的脚。甚至在创建一个新对象时，构造函数都可能会失败，这并不显眼。对，对，对。是的，我认为很多人在真正需要使用其他设计模式时却使用了模板。我认为问题在于，一旦你在 C++ 中使用了模板，其他人也必须开始使用它。因此，由于特化工作的方式以及所有这些原因，你最终会陷入一团糟。就像我看到的那样，举个好例子。你可能会说，我想要一个合成时钟。
So I want this class to take in a clock, and it can ask the clock what the time is. And so when it asks the real clock, it gets the real time. But when I'm running tests, I want it to ask my fake clock, and my fake clock to always say it's midnight or something. And so if you're writing this in Python, you would pass in a clock, or maybe you'd use a singleton, but most people would just pass in a clock. And so you'd pass in the real clock when you want to do that. With C++, you have templates. So you could have a template parameter be the clock. The problem is now that bleeds into everything like if i pass my
所以我希望这个类接收一个时钟，它可以向时钟询问时间。当它询问真实时钟时，它会得到真实时间。但当我在运行测试时，我希望它询问我的虚拟时钟，并且我的虚拟时钟总是说现在是午夜或类似的时间。所以如果你用 Python 编写这段代码，你会传入一个时钟，或者你可能会使用单例模式，但大多数人只会传入一个时钟。因此，当你想要这样做时，你会传入真实的时钟。而在 C++ 中，你有模板。所以你可以让模板参数成为时钟。问题是，现在这会渗透到所有地方，如果我把我的
my class to somebody else they need to know about the clock because it's not just handled through the through the polymorphism anymore and so that's that's one example but i've just seen so much uh pain around uh you know recursive pound defines and crazy templates and all of that. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. And that's, you know, in order to understand what you just say, you really need to understand what templates are doing behind the scenes. So after you're running the compiler, before it's getting to the linker, what's the end
类传给其他人，他们必须了解这个时钟，因为它不再仅仅通过多态性来处理了。所以这是一个例子。但我见过太多围绕递归宏定义、疯狂模板等带来的痛苦。哦，是的。哦，是的。为了理解你刚才所说的话，你确实需要理解模板在底层是如何运作的。所以在编译器运行之后、进入链接器之前，最终结果是什么？
result? Like what the templates are actually doing to your code in order to understand the potential implications like what you just mentioned. And that's in general my recommendation to any engineer and any data scientist. Whatever you decide to do, make sure to understand it very, very deeply and how it works behind the scenes. I think it's very important. Yeah, that's so true. I think with I think with Python, every day, I'm kind of amazed by what things are built into the language. There's like a key value store like Berkeley DB, I think, or level DB, one of these is actually built into Python. Like you can just say,
模板对你的代码实际做了什么，以便理解潜在的影响，就像你刚才提到的一样。总的来说，这是我对任何工程师和数据科学家的建议。无论你决定做什么，都要确保非常非常深入地理解它以及它在底层的运作方式。我认为这非常重要。是的，千真万确。我觉得使用 Python 时，我每天都会对语言内置的功能感到惊叹。比如一个键值存储，像 Berkeley DB，或者 Level DB，其中一个其实是内置在 Python 里的。就像你可以直接说，
yeah, import, you know, BDB, there's just crazy amounts of stuff built in there. And, you know, I think in the case of c++ i mean there's the stl which is constantly expanding but it's less about like all these batteries are included and more about as you said understanding the craft so you can craft like something really beautiful yeah and if you're going with the c++ route maybe you know golang could be a good alternative for that. Yep. Yeah. Golang is super, super clean. I think if you're doing really low level stuff, actually Rust recently made it into the Linux kernel. So you could even write kernel drivers in Rust now. So that's looking pretty nice. And then this Carbon thing from Google,
导入 BDB，里面有大量疯狂的内置功能。我认为对于 C++ 来说，标准模板库（STL）在不断扩展，但它较少关乎所有这些开箱即用的功能，而更多地像你所说的那样理解这门手艺，这样你就可以打造出真正精美的东西。是的，如果你打算走 C++ 路线，也许 Go 语言会是一个不错的替代方案。是的。Go 语言非常非常干净。如果你在做非常底层的事情，事实上，Rust 最近进入了 Linux 内核。所以你现在甚至可以用 Rust 编写内核驱动程序。所以这看起来相当不错。然后谷歌的这个 Carbon，
who knows? I mean, it's so early, but it has a lot of big names behind it. Yeah, interesting. I didn't know, like, how's the performance of running Rust drivers? That's a good question. You know, it's, there are a bunch of really, really fanatical people about Rust. And so if you search in Rust performance, you'll be dominated, the search will be dominated by people telling you it's a million times faster than anything. It would be amazing to get someone on the show who's done embedded stuff in Rust. That would be phenomenal. I don't know, Patrick, have you ever used Rust? You do more embedded work. I haven't, but I think the end result when you use it in device drivers and stuff is it's
谁知道呢？我的意思是，它还处于早期阶段，但它的背后有很多大名鼎鼎的名字。是的，有趣。我不知道，运行 Rust 驱动程序的性能怎么样？这是个好问题。有一群非常狂热的 Rust 粉丝。所以如果你搜索 Rust 性能，搜索结果将被那些告诉你它比任何东西快数百万倍的人所主导。如果能请到一位在 Rust 中做过嵌入式开发的人来到节目中，那就太棒了。那将是了不起的。我不知道，帕特里克（Patrick），你用过 Rust 吗？你做更多嵌入式工作。我没有，但我认为当你在设备驱动程序等中使用它时，最终结果
supposed to be pretty indistinguishable. i mean you have to be it's not it's sort of like all those arguments like between c versus c++ people will say oh c is faster and it is true that it is easier to use a feature of c++ that is expensive versus c just won't have that feature and so if you use certain features but it is entirely possible to write C++ code that is on par with C code. So I think the same is true in the Rust paradigm, right? It is entirely possible to write Rust code that uses a ton of dynamic allocation
应该是差不多的。我的意思是，这有点像 C 与 C++ 之间的所有那些争论，人们会说 C 更快，确实更容易使用 C++ 中昂贵的功能，而 C 根本没有那个功能。因此，如果你使用某些功能，完全有可能编写出与 C 代码不相上下的 C++ 代码。所以我认为 Rust 范式也是如此，完全有可能编写出使用大量动态分配的 Rust 代码，
and would not be suitable for use in a kernel driver. Or you write it in another style and you get some of the benefits of the language, but you still get performance. So maybe I'm more old school here but you know when writing this kind of things i'd go with c i want to have full control on what's going on with the memory i don't want any fluid in my code yeah yeah totally i think the the rust memory checking has got to cost something but on the flip side you know it does offer some kind of guarantees. Patrick, you used to do a lot of embedded stuff, right?
并且不适合在内核驱动程序中使用。或者你用另一种风格编写，你获得了该语言的一些好处，但你仍然获得了性能。所以也许我在这里更保守一些，但你知道，在编写这类东西时，我会选择 C，我想要完全控制内存中发生的事情，我不希望代码中有任何杂质。是的，完全同意。我认为 Rust 的内存检查肯定有成本，但另一方面，它确实提供了一些保证。帕特里克，你以前做过很多嵌入式开发，对吧？
When you were doing the health stuff. So in that, did you do like a balance checking? And did you have a lot of memory sanitization? Or was there just not enough runtime for that? Yeah. I mean, so even just, I mean, I guess it depends. So if you're running bare metal is what we'd call it, right? So you don't have a formal operating system, even getting most of like the memory checks
当你从事医疗相关工作时。那么在那个过程中，你做过边界检查吗？你有很多内存净化吗？还是说没有足够的运行时来进行这些？是的。我的意思是，这取决于情况。如果你运行的是我们所说的裸机（bare metal），对吧？所以你没有正式的操作系统，甚至连你在操作系统中获得的绝大多数内存检查
you would get in an operating system you don't have. So you're accessing just like raw pointers and stuff is memory mapped in. And so that means you're just accessing some address, and there's no ability to do checking. There's no context switching. There's no any of those things. So you don't normally get most of the internal things.
你都没有。所以你只是访问原始指针之类的东西，内存是映射进来的。这意味着你只是访问某个地址，而没有能力进行检查。没有上下文切换，没有这些功能。所以你通常不会得到大部分内部功能。
And C++ doesn't really have a bounds checker. You would have to be using, by convention, we use this abstraction or this library which has it in. So no, we didn't use any of that stuff. Got it. Yeah, that makes sense. I've actually, this is kind of a segue, but every year for Halloween, we do robots that scare the kids for Halloween. And so this year, I got my hands on a bunch of Pico W's, which are these raspberry
而且 C++ 真的没有边界检查器。你必须按照惯例使用这个抽象或包含它的库。所以，不，我们没有使用任何这些东西。明白了。是的，这很有道理。实际上，这算是一个题外话，但每年万圣节，我们都会做一些机器人在万圣节吓唬孩子们。所以今年，我弄到了一堆 Pico W，也就是那些树莓派
pie Picos. They're extremely small. I'm trying to think, they're maybe the size of a stick of gum or something. I mean, they're really tiny, but they have a Wi-Fi chip, which is amazing. And so the plan is, and we actually, it's behind me, ready to go now. It's actually when somebody reaches their hand in the candy dish, this motion sensor fires. And then all the Pico W's are sending little HTTP requests every half a second to this machine saying, hey, have you seen someone? Have you seen someone?
Picos。它们非常小。让我想想，它们大概有一块口香糖那么大。我的意思是，它们真的很小，但它们有一个 Wi-Fi 芯片，这太棒了。所以计划是这样的，实际上它就在我身后，现在随时准备启动。当有人把手伸进糖果盘时，这个运动传感器就会触发。然后所有的 Pico W 每半秒向这台机器发送一次小的 HTTP 请求，说：“嘿，你看到有人了吗？你看到有人了吗？”
As soon as it says yes, all these zombies start rising up from the dead. So it's a lot of fun. And I was able to do that whole thing in MicroPython, which really surprised me. I didn't even know that that had existed until about a week or two ago. It just shows you how powerful even these tiny embedded computers are getting, that they could run Python and it doesn't even matter to them yeah yeah well raspberry pi became very very powerful computer like you can run tons of things on it it became very very intuitive in my opinion yeah these are
一旦它说“看到了”，所有的这些僵尸就会从死里复活。所以这真的很有趣。而且我能够用 MicroPython 完成整个过程，这真的让我很惊讶。直到一两周前，我甚至不知道它的存在。这向你展示了即使是这些微小的嵌入式计算机也变得多么强大，它们可以运行 Python，而且这对它们来说甚至毫无压力。是的，树莓派已经成为一台非常非常强大的计算机，你可以在上面运行大量的东西，在我看来它变得非常非常直观。是的，这些是
these pico w's i think they're i don't know what they're running to be honest patrick do you know like what hardware these guys have i have really no idea but it's it's powerful enough to run this micro python and and uh do a web server and all sorts of other stuff yeah i mean they have their own framework right so it's just it's not running with an os it's sort of like programming in arduino they have like a bunch of libraries sitting around you to help you do common tasks but the way you can kind of there's not like a ton of stuff going on in in parallel and so normally do is the wi-fi stuff is handled by an interrupt like an interrupt will fire and it'll do all the handling uh and then go back to your program but it's not true task switching like you would think about an operating system oh i see got it cool so yeah it. Cool. So yeah, I think, you know, it's ML engineer has a lot of different, you know,
这些 Pico W 运行的到底是什么，说实话，帕 Patrick，你知道这些家伙有什么硬件吗？我真的不知道，但它功能足够强大，可以运行 MicroPython，还能做网页服务器以及各种其他东西。对，我的意思是它们有自己的框架，所以它不是在操作系统上运行，有点像在 Arduino 里编程。它们周围有一堆库来帮助你做常见任务，但你的程序中并没有大量的事情在并行发生。所以通常的做法是，Wi-Fi 相关的事情是由中断处理的，一个中断会触发并处理所有事情，然后再回到你的程序，但这并不是你想象的那种真正的操作系统级别的任务切换。哦，我明白了，原来是这样。酷。所以，我觉得，你知道，机器学习工程师有很多不同的，你知道，
kind of traits, you might have to do serving side, you have to do C++, you might not have to write a device driver, but you never know, you might have to do that. But you definitely have to be really concerned about latency. You know, I think whether it's a web app or definitely anything in the financial industry. And so how do those folks kind of keep the latency down? And how do they fight that monster? So to be honest, you'd be surprised, but a lot of times Python is able to meet their required latency goals. And when it's not, what we see is the most often thing is just taking the model, translating
各种特质，你可能需要做服务端，你可能需要用 C++，你可能不需要写设备驱动程序，但你永远说不准，也许你还真得做那个。但你绝对需要非常关注延迟。你知道，无论是网页应用还是金融行业的任何应用，都是如此。那么这些人是如何把延迟降下来的呢？他们是如何对抗这个怪兽的呢？说实话，你可能会感到惊讶，但很多时候 Python 能够满足他们所需的延迟目标。而当它无法满足时，我们看到最常见的事情就是拿出这个模型，把它翻译
it into Golang, and writing a microservice that runs this Golang-based model. And that's it. Oh, nice. It's not as big an issue as I thought it would be. Yeah. Oh, that is super cool.
成 Golang，并编写一个运行这个基于 Golang 模型的微服务。就是这样。哦，不错。这并没有我想象的那么大问题。对。哦，这太酷了。
Yeah, that's the issue. As soon as you go into C++ now, or even issue as soon as you go into c++ now or even just as soon as you go into anything else now you have your training code in one language and your serving code in the other and so if you have some kind of feature transformation and it's not perfect uh you know it's not exactly the same in both languages, then you start introducing all these errors and that can kind of go wildly out of control. Yeah, and I think that's part of the reason that we see more and more just Python being used both for training and for serving.
对，问题就在这里。一旦你转向 C++，或者甚至一旦你转向其他任何语言，你的训练代码用的是一种语言，而你的服务代码用的是另一种语言。所以如果你有一些特征转换，而它不够完美，你知道，在两种语言中并非完全一致，那么你就会开始引入各种错误，这可能会变得完全失控。是的，我认为这也是为什么我们看到越来越多的人同时将 Python 用于训练和服务的关键原因。
And as for the transformations, I think that Apache Spark became very, very popular. So you can use Apache Spark both for training and for serving. In serving, it's one fork in real-time. It would be more for batch models than real-time models. Oh, cool. I didn't know that. Neat. So yeah, I think we
至于数据转换，我认为 Apache Spark 变得非常非常受欢迎。所以你可以把 Apache Spark 同时用于训练和推理服务。在服务方面，这是实时系统中的一个分支。它更多地用于批处理模型，而不是实时模型。哦，酷。我之前不知道这个。真棒。所以，我觉得我们
kind of did a really good 360. We covered pretty much all of the different aspects of being an ML engineer. If this stuff all sounds exciting to you, then you might have a new career to look forward to. You should definitely dive into it. And it's growing at, you said, what, 30%, 40% annually.
做了一次非常彻底的全方位探讨。我们涵盖了成为一名机器学习工程师的几乎所有不同方面。如果这一切听起来让你感到兴奋，那么你可能会迎来一个新的职业前景。你绝对应该深入了解一下。而且它的增长速度，你刚才说每年大概是多少，30% 到 40%。
So there's a ton of folks who are going to be looking for people with that skill set. So why don't we talk a little bit, shift gears and talk about Aporia. So is Aporia, how does that relate to ML engineering? Is it a tool for those folks or is it kind of a supplement? How does that work? Sure. So Aporia is an observability platform dedicated for machine learning. What does that mean? It means that the Hoya will usually come, will usually integrate with the existing ML platform of the organization. And it allows the ML engineer really to have one centralized place where they can see which models are currently running in production,
所以有大量的人在寻找具备这种技能组合的人才。那么我们为什么不聊聊，换个话题来谈谈 Aporia 呢？那么 Aporia，它与机器学习工程有什么关系？它是给这些人用的工具，还是某种补充？这是怎么运作的？当然。所以 Aporia 是一个专门针对机器学习的可观测性平台。这意味着什么？这意味着 Aporia 通常会与企业现有的机器学习平台进行集成。它真正允许机器学习工程师拥有一个集中的地方，在那里他们可以看到当前有哪些模型在生产环境中运行，
what decisions they're making for the business. You can create your own dashboards and your own custom metrics, and you can define monitors within Aporia. So you can get alerts where there's a drift or data integrity issue. So all the different incidents that we've discussed about in the last hour
它们为业务做出了什么决策。你可以创建自己的仪表板和自定义指标，还可以在 Aporia 中定义监控。这样当出现数据漂移或数据完整性问题时，你就可以收到警报。因此，我们在过去一小时内讨论过的所有不同事件
could be identified with Aporia. And one of the cool things with Aporia is the fact that the system is super customizable up to the point that you can actually write python code within our system and let aporia actually run it for you so it's as customizable as it gets very cool so so someone can say things like uh you know keep track of my, and they might have some key performance metrics for their team or their company. And they say, I'm going to feed to you
都可以通过 Aporia 来识别。Aporia 的酷炫之处之一在于，该系统具有极高的可定制性，甚至你实际上可以在我们的系统中编写 Python 代码，让 Aporia 替你运行它。所以它是你能想象到的最具定制性的系统，非常酷。因此，有人可以说出类似“追踪我的……”之类的话，他们可能会为其团队或公司设定一些关键绩效指标。然后他们说，我将向你提供
the performance metrics each day. And then you could do some anomaly detection. And then maybe I even feed you the performance per model. And so if a model starts underperforming, boom, they get a Slack or email or something, or SMS or something. Exactly. Just sometimes
每天的绩效指标。然后你可以进行异常检测。接着也许我甚至会把每个模型的绩效提供给你。因此，如果某个模型开始表现不佳，轰的一声，他们就会收到 Slack 消息、电子邮件或者短信什么的。完全正确。只是有时候
you're calculating performance metrics on live production data is a bit more complex. So Aporia is actually doing it for you. So all you need to report to Aporia is the feature vector, like the inputs of the model and the predictions. And when you have ground truth,
你在实时生产数据上计算绩效指标会稍微复杂一些。所以 Aporia 实际上是在替你做这件事。你只需要向 Aporia 报告特征向量，比如模型的输入和预测结果。当你拥有真实标签时，
you can also report it asynchronously. And Aporia will calculate, you know, F1 score, precision, recall, all these metrics on its own and will identify anomalies. Oh, very cool. And so how does that work? So you hook up Aporia, let's say you're training using like PyTorch Lightning or something. Is there sort of like an Aporia callback that you do during training? Yeah, exactly. So there is a Python SDK or REST API that you can use to integrate it with your serving. And from there, Apoya will just have this data and work with it. Cool, that makes sense.
你也可以异步报告它。Aporia 将自行计算 F1 分数、准确率、召回率等所有这些指标，并识别出异常。哦，非常酷。那么这是怎么运作的呢？所以你连接了 Aporia，假设你正在使用 PyTorch Lightning 或类似工具进行训练。在训练期间是否有类似 Aporia 回调函数的东西？对，完全正确。所以你可以使用 Python SDK 或 REST API 将其与你的服务集成。从那时起，Aporia 就会拥有这些数据并对其进行处理。酷，这说得通。
So is it like, I guess, scraping the calls to TensorBoard or something? Or do you manually tell Apoya, like here's the loss, here's the other metrics? Oh, no, so you just, so you can think about it like you do with any other logging library, right? So after you call to model.predict or predictPrava, you'd call to aporia.logPrediction.
那么它就像是，我猜，抓取对 TensorBoard 或其他东西的调用吗？还是说你手动告诉 Aporia，比如损失函数在这里，其他指标在这里？哦，不是的，所以你只需，你可以把它想象成你使用的任何其他日志记录库一样。所以在调用 model.predict 或 predictProba 之后，你会调用 aporia.logPrediction。
You'll pass the feature vector, like the data frame, as well as the prediction data frame. Behind the scenes, Aporia will report it to the back end of our system. This information. Internally, our system will calculate all sorts of aggregations and metrics on your live production data. It will also use training as a baseline
你将传入特征向量，比如数据框，以及预测数据框。在幕后，Aporia 会将这些信息报告给我们系统的后端。在内部，我们的系统将在你的实时生产数据上计算各种聚合和指标。它还将使用训练数据作为该行为的基线，
for that behavior, and it will find anomalies. Got it. Cool. So how do people like, you know, let's say, let's transition a little bit from individual now to some giant. Let's say I work for, you know, giant, you know, let's say, let's transition a little bit from individual now to some giant, let's say I work for, you know, giant, you know, Corporation X, and giant Corporation X wants to keep all their data in house, and they have all this paranoia about everything. You know, how do you, how does that work? Can you put a Porya into someone else's, you know, virtual private cloud?
并以此来发现异常。明白了。酷。那么人们是怎么，你知道的，比方说，让我们现在把话题从个人过渡到某个庞然大物。假设我在，你知道，庞大的，你知道的，比方说，让我们从个人过渡到某个庞然大物，假设我在，你知道，庞大的 X 公司工作，而庞大的 X 公司希望将所有数据都留在内部，并且他们对所有事情都抱有各种偏执。你知道，你怎么，这该怎么运作？你可以把 Aporia 放到别人的，你知道的，虚拟私有云中吗？
Yeah, so it's a great question. And it's not only for large, huge enterprises and corporates. I think that when it comes to machine learning, businesses are always very, very sensitive about it. It could be PII, it could be their business sensitive information. They don't want to share it with an external vendor for whatever reason. So Appoya was built from the very first day in security in mind. So, you'll only deploy a very small workload on your VPC. This will be the only part that touches the data.
是的，这是一个很好的问题。而且这不仅适用于大型企业和公司。我认为当涉及到机器学习时，企业对此总是非常非常敏感。这可能是个人身份信息（PII），也可能是他们商业敏感的信息。无论出于何种原因，他们都不想与外部供应商共享这些信息。因此，Aporia 从第一天起就是将安全性放在首位构建的。所以，你只需在你的 VPC 上部署一个非常轻量的工作负载。这将是唯一触及数据的部分。
It will calculate the aggregations and metrics, and then APOYA will do the rest for you. So, no sensitive data will ever leave the organization's VPC, for example. I see. So you have, maybe to use the term from Datadog, you have an agent that runs in someone's VPC, and then by the time the data exits that agent, it's aggregated at such a coarse granularity that you don't have to worry about.
它会计算聚合和指标，然后 Aporia 会为你处理剩下的事情。因此，例如，没有任何敏感数据会离开组织的 VPC。我明白了。所以你可能用 Datadog 的术语来说，你在某个人的 VPC 中运行一个代理，等数据离开该代理时，它已经被聚合到非常粗的粒度，以至于你无需担心。
Exactly. Cool. That makes sense. Yeah. So I see. And so then once the data, so then folks can go to Aporia and see how their models are doing in aggregate and all of that. And then that can feed back into tickets for the developers and all of that, and then that can feed back into tickets for the developers and all of that. Yeah, like you can connect it with your Jira, for example, create tickets, for example, saying, well, we have new data, we need to retrain our model. Maybe we have segment of our data that the model is underperforming.
完全正确。酷。这说得通。是的。所以明白了。然后人们可以访问 Aporia，查看他们的模型在总体上的表现等等。然后这些反馈可以转化为开发人员的工单等等，然后这些反馈可以转化为开发人员的工单等等。是的，你可以将它与你的 Jira 连接，例如创建工单，说明“我们有新数据，我们需要重新训练模型”。也许我们的数据中有一部分模型的表现不佳。
Maybe it will be worthwhile training a separate model that will be built dedicated for that kind of data segment. So you can drive insights from the system and then connect it to the rest of your tooling that you're using. Cool. That makes sense. It sounds like another layer on segment. So it's something like segment segment you can say i hope i'm using getting the right name but there's there's a company pretty short segment where you can say like different rules so you know when this amazon queue grows too large then send a slack message and a text message to bob or something right and so segment lets you kind of connect all these different rules. Or when I get something in this queue,
也许为这种数据段专门构建一个单独的模型是值得的。因此，你可以从系统中获取洞察，然后将其连接到你正在使用的其余工具链中。酷。这说得通。听起来像是 Segment 上的另一层。所以它是类似 Segment 的东西，你可以说——希望我没有用错名字——但有一家名叫 Segment 的公司，你可以为其设置不同的规则，所以你知道当这个 Amazon 队列变得太大时，就向 Bob 发送一条 Slack 消息和一条短信，诸如此类，对吧？所以 Segment 可以让你连接所有这些不同的规则。或者当我在此队列中收到某物时，
put it into this data lake site, right? And so you're doing that plus like a piece on the front to kind of filter and to do some pre-processing. So like, you're getting a, not every single feature vector needs to be an SMS to somebody, but you're getting all these feature vectors and then saying, oh, I've hit some threshold now, which is defined by the person who's using a Porya. Now I need to send something to somebody. Yeah. So you can either define it, really build the sentencing when there is a data drift
把它放进这个数据湖里，对吧？所以你正在做的是，再加上前端的一个用于过滤和做一些预处理的部分。所以，你得到的是——并不是每一个特征向量都需要变成发给某人的短信——但你得到了所有这些特征向量，然后说：“哦，我已经达到了由使用 Aporia 的人所定义的某个阈值。现在我需要向某人发送点东西。”是的。所以你要么可以定义它，真正地建立这种判定：当我的流失预测模型中出现数据漂移时，
in my churn prediction model, send an alert on Slack channel to Jason, for example. Right, so you can do that. But you can also use a pointer to create your own dashboards. You know, you want to see what the impact of your model is making. You want to explore the different behavior of the data, like distributions, how different metrics are changing over time. So you can see all of that and create your own dashboard. Oh, that is super cool. Does it plug into these different dashboard things
在 Slack 频道上向 Jason 发送警报，例如。没错，你可以这样做。但你也可以使用 Aporia 创建你自己的仪表板。你知道的，你想看看你的模型正在产生什么影响。你想探索数据的不同行为，比如分布、不同的指标随时间如何变化。所以你可以看到所有这些并创建你自己的仪表板。哦，这太酷了。它能接入这些不同的仪表板工具吗，
like Superset and what's another one? But yeah, there's a whole bunch of these different, Looker, like Superset and and looker does it plug into those um no so it just like the solution itself is kind of a web service it's like any other sass solution you sign up you log in um you get your dashboards you can do the integration you can set up alerts so it's within the Aporia system, the dashboarding part. Okay. Very cool. What about folks who are just graduating or they're in the final years of university? Are there internships? Are there full-time positions? And is it remote? Is it local?
比如 Superset 还有另一个是什么？但是的，有一大堆这样的工具，Looker，比如 Superset 和 Looker，它能接入那些工具吗？呃，不能，所以它就像是解决方案本身是一种网络服务，它就像任何其他的 SaaS 解决方案一样，你注册，你登录，你获取你的仪表板，你可以进行集成，你可以设置警报，所以仪表板部分是在 Aporia 系统内部完成的。好的。非常酷。对于那些刚刚毕业或者正处于大学最后几年的朋友们呢？有实习机会吗？有全职职位吗？它是远程办公的还是线下的？
What's the state of hiring over there? Sure. So we're constantly growing. We raised our series of $25 million not that long ago. Oh, congrats. Thank you very much. So we are very, very happy always to have more skillful and smart people join our team. So definitely. Very cool. What about interns, like summer internships? A lot of smaller companies don't really do that yet. Is that a thing at Aporia or not yet? So we're doing it kind of on an opportunistic basis. So we've done it a couple of times in the past,
那里的招聘情况怎么样？当然。所以我们一直在发展。不久前我们刚完成了 2500 万美元的 A 轮融资。哦，恭喜。非常感谢。所以我们非常非常高兴能有更多技术娴熟、聪明的人加入我们的团队。所以绝对欢迎。非常酷。实习生呢，比如暑期实习？很多小公司其实还不做这个。Aporia 现在有这个吗，还是还没有？所以我们是根据具体情况随缘招收的。我们过去做过几次，
and it's case by case. Got it. Cool. Yeah, we'll post a link to Aporia careers or jobs page, we'll find the appropriate link to that and put that in the show notes. Great. Well, this is super exciting. What is one unique thing about working at Aporia? So it's something that is kind of special that you do that kind of makes it distinct? You know, it could be, you know, there's football tournaments on Thursdays, or it could be a team outing that you all do or anything like that. I think we're solving a very, very interesting, impactful and challenging problems and what you'll find if you ask people working in aporia people that are here for two two and a half years you'll hear that they're still learning
都是具体情况具体分析。明白了。酷。是的，我们会在 Shownotes 中发布指向 Aporia 招聘或职位页面的链接，我们会找到合适的链接并把它放在 Shownotes 里。太棒了。好吧，这太令人兴奋了。在 Aporia 工作的一个独特之处是什么？有什么比较特别的事情是你们在做的，让它显得与众不同？你知道，这可能是周四有足球锦标赛，或者可能是你们大家一起进行的团队出游，诸如此类的事情。我认为我们在解决非常非常有趣、极具影响力且具有挑战性的问题，如果你问在 Aporia 工作的人，那些在这里呆了两年、两年半的人，你会听到他们仍然在每天学习
new a lot of new things every day so i think that's pretty crazy right like usually it happens only within the first month when you join the company but that's not the case here. Very cool. That is awesome. Yeah, well, this is filling a huge need in the community. I think that I really haven't come across like an anomaly detection as a service and kind of model tracking as a service. It's a huge, huge opportunity. And I'm really excited that we were able to get you on the show.
很多新东西。所以我觉得这太疯狂了，对吧？因为通常这种情况只发生在你加入公司的第一个月，但这里并非如此。非常酷。这太棒了。是的，嗯，这填补了社区里的一个巨大空白。我觉得我真的没有遇到过即服务的异常检测和即服务的模型跟踪。这是一个巨大、巨大的机遇。我非常高兴我们能请你上节目。
And I'm going to definitely be following this and see where it goes. Thank you. Thank you very much for having me. I really enjoyed the conversation. Cool. And thanks, everybody, for listening. Thanks for supporting us on Patreon and on Audible. It's always kind of special to get emails.
我肯定会一直关注这个项目，看看它未来的发展。谢谢。非常感谢邀请我。我很享受这次对话。酷。也谢谢大家的收听。感谢大家在 Patreon 和 Audible 上对我们的支持。收到电子邮件总是让人感觉很特别。
We got actually a lot of folks have been emailing us lately, you know, about always kind of special to get emails we got um actually a lot of uh folks have been emailing us lately you know about their kind of experiences and you know it is you know a rather tough labor market so um you know it's always extra special when people reach out and they say hey i've got ramped up on some new skills thanks for programmingdown. I got a job at this place. Everything makes us, kind of warms our heart, fills our bucket. So thank you for that.
实际上最近我们收到很多人的电子邮件，你知道，关于他们那种特殊的感受，收到邮件总是很特别，我们，实际上最近有很多朋友给我们发邮件，你知道的，关于他们的各种经历，你知道的，这确实是一个相当艰难的劳动力市场，所以，你知道，当人们伸出援手并说：“嘿，我在编程大乱斗（Programming Throwdown）的帮助下掌握了一些新技能，我在某个地方找到工作了。”时，总是格外特别。这一切都让我们，感觉心里暖洋洋的，动力十足。所以非常感谢你们。
And we will catch you on a couple of weeks. Music by Eric Barndollar. music by eric barnmeller programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们几周后再见。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。您可以自由共享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音和改编，但您必须对帕特里克和我进行署名，并以相同的许可分享。本期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。